Now.
Oh Shit.
That means we're live ladies and gentlemen,
the Joe Rogan.
Oh,
I'm trying,
I had,
this is the first time ever of using this laptop and right now it's making noise
and I don't know how to shut the noise off cause I'm a simple man and the only
knows how to you use a Macintosh.
This bitch there it's way down in the corner.
This is my first time using windows since I was a small child.
So if you hear an echo folks,
all right,
that should be it.
That's it,
right?
Yeah.
Doesn't see me anymore.
Now this computer's trying to give me a tutorial.
Just,
just recently started using these alien where computers,
cause a Alienware is a company that supports a lot of MMA fighters and they
sponsor a lot of MMA fighters and I thought it would be cool to a,
to use their products.
So,
um,
I got uh,
three Alienware laptops.
I got this thing was,
this is the [inaudible] 18,
I believe it's called.
This is fucking ridiculous.
This thing.
And in honor of our guests today,
Giorgio sucralose from ancient aliens.
Perfect God damn laptop for this show.
But,
uh,
this is the biggest laptop I've ever seen in my life.
It's a fucking foldable Imac.
That thing is ridiculous.
He's in keyboard.
I love the light board is fucking deal.
It feels like you're using something you're not supposed to you,
you know,
you're fucking around with it.
It's all,
it's like a science fiction movie.
It's sick.
It's really cool.
The,
the size of it is daunting,
but you know what?
I'm a fucking manly man.
I can carry a laptop.
You know what I'm saying,
son?
No,
I can see you Jo.
I don't give a fuck.
I don't have to see me anyway.
Um,
so,
uh,
our sponsors if you want.
Uh,
so anyway,
check out the Alienware laptops cause they're pretty bad ass.
I'm like I said,
they do support,
uh,
MMA fighters.
So that's a while we have decided to start using them.
So,
um,
it can make this a mutually beneficial situation.
You know what I'm saying?
And I'll give you a full details on how would I think about this thing.
My friend,
Voodoo chicken has one of these.
He,
uh,
he swears by it.
He loves that.
If you're going to buy a laptop and you want it to have some balls,
that's definitely the way to go.
I mean like you're not going to fucking go get a compact or you know,
is this my past top?
It's a desktop.
You can carry route.
Right?
But you fucking carried her out bitch.
Why?
Why do you need everything so light,
you know?
Do you know what a backpack is?
Yeah.
You throw a backpack on and then he could take the laptop with me.
You Fuck?
Have you seen the lady at Starbucks?
It's usually a lady.
I've only seen it in two different ladies who bring their whole entire tower to
the computer.
Like if there's this woman that always brings,
she has a tower,
a step,
something like a 17 inch monitor.
She has,
you know,
her power brick.
She has a keyboard and mouse and she sets up like her office and he just works
there for four hours.
Five hours.
That's crazy.
Do poor people do that because it's the internet.
I think it's just because it's not a laptop.
Do you get free internet?
Yeah,
and when you go to Starbucks,
you get free Internet.
So maybe that's why a lot of people are working there.
They just can't afford internet.
Tough Times.
Brian,
just imagine the process of having to do this every day.
Well,
it's for a poor person though,
that can't afford the Internet.
It's probably a good deal.
What does,
what is good internet costs?
Like 50 bucks a month or so?
I don't know.
Because nowadays you can get fucking like your DSL for like $10 a month.
Wow.
If you got to cut you back,
you've got to cut back two times are tough.
And she's in the middle of writing the great American supreme screenplay.
That's right.
Right.
The greatest movie ever.
It's about vampires who make love to women and become aliens.
That's what it's going to be like.
Yeah.
We're going to have to add aliens to the mix.
Our sponsors for this fucking ridiculous show.
First of all,
the one and only of course,
the flashlight,
our first original sponsor,
uh,
we still support them.
God dammit.
Spite.
It's ridiculous.
It's like God damn solid product kits.
Shouldn't say too many.
God Damn was already pretty much used them up for the show bananas.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the fleshlight and enter in
the code named Rogan,
you will save yourself 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
And like I said,
it's a God damn solid product.
It's,
yeah,
it's embarrassing.
But be a,
be a man,
man.
The fuck up and go fuck one of those things that's really,
really,
try it without the plastic case.
Once in a while it's totally different because you getting them really squeezed.
They're rubber and have like a really tight,
so you do it without the plastic gets in a while.
It's a little different.
So you're basically tricking yourself off with the snake.
Well,
it's just like grabbing your dig,
but with rubber in between it so you don't feel your hand on your Dick.
So it's a little different.
Try it out.
It's called fish out of the bucket and fish out of the bucket.
Fleshlight tips by red ban.
All right.
In a,
we are also brought to you by [inaudible] Dot com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain.
I didn't fucking bring my house.
Got You.
Some Alpha brain for you.
Shut that shit this way.
Um,
we all,
we also have a,
a bunch of fitness equipment.
We just started a caring,
uh,
including the best quality kettle bells available there.
They're these York kettle bells.
We're selling them as cheap as possible.
It's,
it's very,
it's the whole thing like collecting this and selling,
selling kettle bells and shipping them.
It's a huge can't of a pain the ass.
You're basically sending cannon balls through the fucking mail.
I mean,
they're ridiculous.
They're,
you know,
it's this cheap as we can sell them folks,
but it is the best quality and they will last forever.
These things are solid iron and it is an amazing workout.
It is the only workout that I do now as far as lifting weights,
all I do,
I do kettle bells,
I do body weight squats and I do chin ups.
That's,
that's all I do every,
almost every exercise because I'm interested in functional strength.
I'm interested in the leg strength that I can use for Jujitsu.
And for me it turned out that like when I lifted weights,
like doing curls and bench press and stuff,
it's certainly helped because I was stronger.
But it doesn't make you use your body athletically,
use your body as one big unit.
And that's what kettlebells do.
Kettlebells are like full body exercises.
You're out and it's it in play in the real
world.
Like I bought a bag of dog food the other day and uh,
it was a couple bags and they were under a bunch of cat litter fucking things.
And uh,
you know,
you go to Petco and you've got to like reach up and pull.
That thing is at the bottom.
I snatched that bitch up in the air 50 pound bag and that lady was like,
wow,
you're so strong.
And I flexed,
I don't want kettlebells.
Yo.
I would've said kettlebells bitch,
but I didn't know her that well and I didn't want it to be all,
you know,
think I was aggressive.
But if you're interested in working out and getting in shape,
it is the best way we dude,
we made them as cheapest humanly fucking possible.
Um,
well that's my whole,
my whole purpose for all this stuff is to give everybody the best shit we can
sell,
sell it at the lowest possible rate with and make it as clean and as easy as
possible.
Like if you buy supplements from us,
the um,
the,
the big one is the cognitive supplement Alpha brain,
which I 100% fucking swear by.
You know,
you can talk with Cbo all day,
but there's plenty of information available online about the efficacy.
Make me what you use.
Big words of supplements and nutrition as far as like enhancing your,
your brain's ability to function.
People with Alzheimer's,
they actually give them certain nootropics in order to stimulate their brain and
they keep it functioning.
Our whole body relies on nutrients.
You need nutrients for everything,
for every,
every cell of your body.
And what these are,
is the best,
most concentrated,
purest form of supplements that we can sell you.
And if you try this shit and he don't like it,
you get 100% of your money back guarantee and your first 30 pills,
you don't even have to return the pills.
I'm so concerned with making sure that people don't feel ripped off.
It's impossible to make people happy.
There's always gonna be someone that's a cunt.
And I try to limit the cont factor as much as humanly possible and that way we
have it set up.
So anything you buy from on it,
whether it's a Alpha brain or any of the other supplements,
first order of 30 pills,
100% money back guarantee.
And if you use a code name,
Rogan,
you saved yourself 10% of that number one sex toy from and what here?
When I go into commercial boat,
I know what I'm doing.
I'm just fucking around fucking around with toys.
Yes.
That's how I,
that's how I roll.
I'm also a,
we have these new battle ropes in which is the latest product at on it.
And if you've ever seen like Brock Lesnar workout with these giant fucking
ropes,
it is ridiculous.
Workout is like,
it's like wrestling a giant fucking snake.
They do this huge heavy,
thick ropes and you tie him to a tree or you can actually loop,
I'm under your kettle bells if you like.
You'll go out to a park,
you could have a bad ass workout just in the grass.
Just bring the ropes and bring the kettle bells and there's some tutorials
online on on it.
And there's this dude,
uh,
shows you a bunch of different exercises in techniques,
techniques you can use with the battle ropes and they will fucking where you
are.
But this is all real functional strength.
You know,
if you,
if you want to like be able to carry yourself over a fence,
if you want to be able to pick something up,
you want your body to be stronger in everyday life.
That's what it's all [inaudible].
All this shit that I'm interested in and that's all the shit that we're going to
be interested in on it.
It's funny because at first I thought this was this jump ropes bad know there
were that big cause they're here,
it looks like 40 feet long.
I'm like,
wow,
that's a weird way to sell.
Jump ropes two inches around,
two inches in 40 feet long and check it out.
Watch the checkout.
That video,
if you like,
fast forward the video.
You could see like his exercises there.
It's fucking bad ass man.
What's going on here?
You,
you swing these heavy ass ropes.
Oh,
crazy.
Yeah.
And when you're doing it,
like go to one where you can see him like in the middle of an exercise.
Like here's what you're swinging these giant 40 pound ropes and dude,
you get fucking winded.
It's like a constant wrestling match with an animal.
That's wild.
Yeah.
It's weird because the weight on a giant rope when you're moving you like you've
got to swing it up in the air and the weight's kind of funky.
You know,
it's,
it's all awkward and Shit.
Yeah.
Wobbles.
You're holding it.
You,
you've got to really grab it so your grip gets amazing.
That's one of the things that I've found since I started using kettlebells.
My grip for Jujitsu is way better than it's ever been before.
Just just kettlebells and Chin ups.
And another thing we're going to get into soon,
it's club bells,
club bells or another amazing exercise.
Not that kind of bells,
Brian.
They're,
they're an an ancient Indian form of a,
of working out.
Do I use a 15 pound one?
It's,
that's how hard these extras are.
It's a 15 pound club bell,
15 pounds.
I'm a manly man.
Brian.
It's hard for me to admit that 15 pounds is actually a workout,
but that's how bad ass these ours,
these exercises are.
There's a,
um,
the 35 pound kettle bell workout that will kick your fucking ass.
And I know you like,
I can't work out with a 35 pound weight.
What kind of a girly man am I?
But I'm telling you this as a kettlebell extreme cardio workout and you can get
the video from,
uh,
the company's called dragon door.
See,
I'm not even doing my commercials.
I'm hooking people up for free.
Okay?
I'm not even affiliated with these bitches,
you know.
Uh,
but they have two of them.
He's a,
he's done two of these workouts and they're fucking incredible.
They kick your ass and all you need is one kettle bell and we're eventually
going to have a bunch of different videos that are going to be available for
download on on at.com as well.
We're going to produce them some workouts for people so that you can just press
play and follow along through that.
That's what I like to do.
That's why I like that extreme kettlebell cardio workout because you just press
play and he works out with you and you just,
you just follow what he does and it's Bruno.
He doesn't have to be in your house and creeping you out.
It doesn't have to be weird looking at your dog and should get becoming friends
with your wife,
giving you kissy faces,
send a text message to your kids.
I like white wine.
Cold thing to note is that the prices are insane on the kettle bells because I
was just at target looking at just us single kettlebell and you have like this
thing called the starter pack that comes with three kettle bells.
It governs with a a I believe a 35 uh,
or a 25 if fifth in two fifteens or something like that.
I don't even know what it is.
But you can pull these different combinations.
Yeah,
there's,
there's quite a few different combinations.
There's so it's like it's set up for someone who's like a serious athlete to
someone who is just,
you know,
a small girl who wants to learn some strength and it's one of the,
for women too,
it's not just for men.
It's fucking amazing.
It just things like Turkish getups I'm telling you,
it doesn't seem like you think like to work out you have to do like,
you know like bench press or you have to do curls or,
but the reality is something called the Turkish getup where you just,
you have this little weight,
you put it in your hand and you just practice getting up,
just getting up in a controlled way and extending your arm up in the air.
It's all,
you can watch videos of it.
There's a hundred different videos explaining how to do it online,
but it's an amazing workout and it's great for core strength,
functional strength,
strength that you would actually use in real life if you had a choke a bitch.
It's good idea that the package it like that.
That was cheaper than a single tea kettle bell.
Dot Target.
I see like that one.
The beast.
That's a perfect machine.
Yeah,
the machine.
Yeah.
Powerful,
powerful.
Bert Kreischer.
Um,
yeah.
There's a bunch of different names for the different ones,
the beast,
the machine,
the starter,
but go check it out on it.com.
O.
N.
I.
T use the code name and save yourself some money on some supplements.
You dirty bitches.
Go get your brain right,
son.
All right.
That's it for this.
We will move on now to the actual real podcast.
Holy Shit.
George Ohsu closest here,
trying my day.
Joe Rogan podcast,
my
Paula,
Giorgio,
my man.
We actually do have alien and
where computers in respect for you,
they're pretty dope,
right?
Great.
The whole alien community must be like really excited about your show.
Like people that sell alien ship.
Yeah.
Because if you're a fan of like ancient aliens,
you want to just go out and like buy as much alien shit as possible.
I was just in Roswell for the very first time in my life.
Let's get you closer to the microphone if we can get it right in front of your
face.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Wonderful.
Everybody can hear me.
Testing.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Well I was just in Roswell for the first time,
my life and that's impossible.
I thought you'd been there a hundred times already.
No snooping around.
I haven't.
What's going on?
He tell people who don't know.
Uh,
what,
what the reason for what Roswell,
there's,
there's a few people out there don't understand the story well in Roswell
allegedly there was a Ufo crash or some type of a crash in 1946 1947 and the
next day when the newspaper reported something,
they said that a flying saucer,
a flying disc had crashed there with the potential of,
you know,
one living body.
Out of the three and a three days later there was a retraction of that story
where the government then told the Roswell newspaper,
there you have to print a story that flying saucer
crashed but a weather balloon and it was the only military testing that's the
bay,
basically the Roswell Story.
And,
and ever since Roswell happened over the next 10 15 years,
our technological development in on earth basically snowballed.
There was a company called the American computer company.
Do you remember them?
It was a American computer company,
US computer company,
but it was run by some people who were claiming to have some sort of technology
and some sort of an infer information about the,
the progress of technology as it pertains to the government back engineering
alien spacecrafts on Roswell.
Sure.
I have not heard from that company.
It was a long time ago.
Art Bell Days,
I think he was like a sponsor art bell show or something.
I mean even even the idea of IBM,
there are ideas that the IBM was funded after they exchanged of some type of
information between the government and a themselves after the Roswell crash and
in some exchange of knowledge.
And then ever since then,
you know,
IBM I think is the first company that came out with a computer chip and things
like this.
So the question that Phillip Corso asked himself in his book that they,
after Roswell,
he said,
where did IBM get this technology from?
Because they basically sprung up out of nowhere and then they have this,
this chip.
So what does work though?
Someone like had an invention.
I mean,
wouldn't,
that isn't how things happen.
Like someone had felt some course,
but it do just spring out of nowhere.
It was discussed
and he had basically sprung out of nowhere and you know,
core so had actually worked in the government and so he had all these redacted
documents that he was able to read when they were unredacted and things like
that.
And uh,
so he made a point that he thinks that our,
you know,
very quick industrial revolution and everything else too until you know,
putting a man on the moon and now we're in the international space station and
things like this that,
you know,
is this acceleration of technology must have had some type of an
extraterrestrial origin.
And he placed it on,
on Roswell in 1946 47.
That sounds ridiculous.
But if,
but if it was true,
what a fucking,
what a mind fuck that they found a crash sauce and what,
how fuck are they doing this?
And they backed the whole thing up.
I have that Roswell,
a newspaper clipping on my wall.
I have a print of it framed on my wall.
It's a,
it's crazy to look at.
It's crazy to look at.
But you know,
you,
you stop and think if it was some sort of government craft,
how many people would have been in the know and if it was some sort of,
uh,
you know,
they know the Nazis back then had some Ufo looking devices,
they had some flying discs.
Sure.
Which is a,
makes you wonder like what came first the chicken or the egg,
right.
Did they see some shit and try to like,
it was like Whoa,
how fuck did they do in that?
We've got to figure out how to make one of those.
Right,
exactly.
You know,
I mean why,
why make a disk?
Why,
what are you doing?
Where are you getting that idea from?
Why is it a disc?
Is the disc supposed to come from a mothership?
Do they have theories on that?
To be honest with you personally,
I have no idea because I really am not into modern a UFO stories and stuff like
this.
However I've been told and due to the shape,
cause apparently these things they spin and they spin.
They create some type of a vortex or an energy field,
and that's how they're able to travel.
So I guess that's the best shape for again,
sounds completely ridiculous.
And let us,
you stop and think about like how about these cave paintings that they recently
found that,
uh,
turn out to be a lot older than they thought.
And our result is 40,000 years ago,
which is making people think that it perhaps in the enter talls even,
uh,
we're doing cave art.
It wasn't just a homosapien and not only that,
but what many people don't realize is that neanderthal and Homo sapiens
coexisted.
Yes.
And then in a bread bowl essentially then died out.
But yes,
absolutely.
And a lot of [inaudible] and that was something that five years ago was
completely anathema.
Nobody talked about it.
And then the research came out at,
hold on a second,
we found these new fossils and man,
they coexisted.
So why did Neanderthal Diet over homosapiens?
Because neanderthal was stronger,
had bigger brains,
a bigger bone structure.
So if the whole survival of the fittest evolution theory were true,
then logically you would have to say that neanderthal should've won out over
homosapiens cause we're puny compared to home with SAPE.
Well they were,
there were short,
but they were really like stalky and wide.
Yes.
Elsewhere.
But there's stupid as fuck.
So we ganged him.
That's how it works.
But that's the big question.
Allegedly,
not allegedly,
but they had bigger brains.
Right.
So does an elephant.
Yeah.
But it's the size of the body.
They were like five foot three and they were over 200 pounds.
They had like really thick bones and they would probably be beat the shit out of
us.
They were collect closer to chimps than than we are,
which is why I'm,
I always say I'm mostly Niana tall.
Probably.
If I had to go back and look at my gene pool,
I'm sure someone got fucked by a cave man.
You would.
Yeah.
My point was if you,
um,
if you look at that cave art from 40,000 years ago and look at anything that we
do today,
it would seem completely impossible.
And 40,000 years in the span of the universe is literally nothing,
a blip.
Not even nothing.
Not even,
you can't,
you can't even wrap your head around it.
So whenever I talk to someone who's skeptical about aliens or time travel or
anything,
and I was like,
bitch,
you are using magic right now.
You're,
you're on a phone,
you're talking to someone,
nowhere near you with a device that you can also talk to and get fucking answers
from about virtually anything.
You talk to it.
You ask it,
you know who created the Sistine Chapel?
Who did the painting,
you know,
Oh,
it wasn't me,
Michael and Oh we,
in order to Vinci,
which one of those motherfuckers was it?
Did they find out instantly on your goddamn phone?
Some shit that happened thousands of years ago.
So for us to even like,
well of course it's possible.
Something could have an energy vortex.
There you go.
Siri's talking to you.
You could have something some day that travels by virtue of some sort of anti
gravitational field or some new type of,
you know,
uh,
some sort of a harnessing of anti matter.
I mean,
there's so many possibilities as you look at energy sources and then you,
you sort of have to extrapolate how far we've come in such a blip of time and
then think of a thousand years,
think of a million years,
a million years.
Ain't shit for the universe.
A million years is nothing.
I mean,
there's certain stars that have lives that are much,
much longer than ours.
Like our star is only going to last for like a few billion years,
right?
Yes.
And then it'd be done,
done.
And then everything on this planet,
it's going to be done too.
But they're stars that been fine forever.
You know,
there's stars that lasts much longer and they live in solar systems that don't
have er asteroids in them.
That's possible too.
It's every solar system doesn't have some fucking gigantic asteroid belt like we
did right.
Between Mars and Jupiter,
there's hundreds of thousands of these near Earth objects that could just fuck
everything up.
All they have to do is come flying in and it could happen any second if and when
people don't know is Jupiter saves us.
If it wasn't for Jupiter,
there was no way we'd be this stable Jupiter and our moon.
Those two things are critical.
Our Moon to keep our,
our,
our orbit very stable and very similar like it,
it doesn't vary too much.
And the Jupiter is the,
like the magnet for all the asteroids and the,
this amateur astronomers who have caught like recent asteroid impacts.
It was Jupiter,
Saturn,
I can't remember which one it was.
Pretty sure it was Jupiter.
But yeah,
it was Jupiter.
It was a big fucking impact.
And this amateur astronomer caught it.
So their shit how fair this shit out there that comes fucking flying down.
If we lived in a place that didn't have that shit out there.
So if there was a water base planet like ours and some place that didn't have
the same issues,
they could,
they could exist a million years longer than us.
Wrap your head around that because they want it.
They wouldn't be extinct at some point.
What us some sort of an impact.
Well,
not only that,
we're late to the game.
This planet is late to the game.
This player zone four billionaires have 4.6 billion years old or something like
that.
People don't understand the universe.
That ain't shit just for what their current understanding of the universe is is
somewhere around 14 plus billion light years old.
God Damn Man,
4 billion years and ain't shit.
That's nothing.
Then you got to wrap your fucking head around the fact that a human being is
actually constructed out of star dust that are the molecules and the the,
the,
the this,
the actual
ingredients for us literally have to be made inside stars and then that star
blows up and then somehow or another it becomes a person.
No,
we are all inside.
If you take a piece of skin and you look at it underneath the electron
microscope,
you see it.
Everything wobbles at the,
the deeper you go into decor,
everything vibrates.
It's all about harmonics.
Now we just looked at a piece of skin.
If you take a piece of stone and you go at the same core,
you see the exact same thing.
You cannot distinguish between the two.
And that to me is absolutely fascinating because it means there really is no
difference between material that's considered organic and inorganic.
One is alive and one is dead,
but is it really dead?
It's not because we all consist of the same stuff or as a you said of star stuff
and that was,
you know,
an idea that a calls Sagan brought forth and you know what,
what better brain than him to to you know,
introduce these ideas because it's crazy.
The across Eggo is an amazing guy.
He actually wrote that movie contact for the folks who don't even know,
which I saw recently and still holds up,
still holds.
It's an amazing solid moving.
We we that alone,
just that.
Just the,
the,
just getting to let,
just the idea of subatomic particles,
just the idea of cells and atoms and molecules,
just the idea of that is way crazier than the idea of aliens.
Sure.
And you know,
what's fascinating to me also is that,
you know,
talking about aliens or other solar systems or actually other galaxies out
there,
uh,
astronomers today have sore or,
yeah,
astronomers have,
have suggested that there are more galaxies in the entire universe than there
are grains of sand on all the beaches in the world.
Now
think about that for just,
that's,
you know,
that's insane.
We're so nothing,
and we're so everything and,
and galaxies.
And each galaxy has billions of,
of solar systems,
each galaxy,
and there's more galaxies than sand,
the grains of sand.
And then ultimately the ultimate mind fuck is that they now believe that inside
every black holes and other universe,
that a black hole is literally a dimensional door.
Something will you,
if you pass through that,
you will literally go into a new fucking universe.
No,
there's hundreds of billions of them because each solar system at the center of
every galaxy is a supermassive black hole.
That's exactly one half of 1% of the entire mass of the galaxy is something they
figured out and the early two thousands they didn't know.
I mean they didn't know that.
They kind of,
there was a bunch of people that knew that that black holes were around,
but the,
to know that they're in the center of every single galaxy and that is directly
proportionate to the size of the galaxy,
the mass,
the black hole,
and the latest idea being that if you went
through that black hole,
that that black hole literally would bring you into another universe that may or
may not be anything like this.
It may be exactly.
It may be that what we're seeing is just like some sort of an operating system
that runs over reality and that we're not just existing in even one universe.
As a person like Lena,
when I say that you can change your life.
If you change your direction,
you can change your life.
You can,
maybe you actually can for real.
Maybe every time you make a decision,
every second of every day a new universe has created with a different,
a different set of probabilities and possibilities and it all operates inside of
the operating system that you've chosen to accept.
You know,
Western civilization America,
2012 Giorgio sucralose with his crazy hair,
Joe Rogan with no hair on computers talk.
I mean what I'm saying like,
but what you actually are might be this like piece of the universe that's
expressing itself through different forms over and over again throughout time.
Like you're,
you,
you are this eternal thing that's a part of this massive thing that's too big
for you to possibly understand.
So your child,
your job is just to try to go along in this,
this,
this path you're doing and create energy.
See if you could figure out what's the,
what's the best way to get the good feelings?
What's the best way to have the best time?
What's the best way to spread the,
but what you're doing is you're like a harvester of energy and that it's just
done through this body in this life and that it's going on everywhere,
all around you,
all the time.
And you literally are the universe.
Right?
And then after having said all of this,
which was absolutely beautiful,
there's still people out there who will say,
we are alone in the universe.
Those people are silly bitches.
That's desk that the Ed to say,
you know,
it's like people who say that Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone,
shut up,
bitch.
There's plenty of information that shows us something was going on.
There's a massive amount of fuckery afoot for you to say in 2012 that you are
sure because I've looked at the information and I just don't see it.
Why don't you're an idiot?
Well,
you're not telling the truth or you have decided that you don't want the world
to be as complicated as it really truly is.
And so you're compartmentalizing no people.
Exactly.
People always have to be ready to accept certain realities they want.
They want laws and rules.
And a lot of water or not ready.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's it.
That's the real thought about aliens.
And that's the one thing when I think if I was the president,
what would I do?
I would definitely not tell people the same mother fuckers that are watching Kim
Kardashian now.
Now I'm not telling you if I knew that there were aliens,
if I knew that there was hanger f 18 out in,
where was it?
Ohio,
right?
Isn't that where they Wright Patterson air force base.
They flew the wreckage of,
that's the other thing.
If you want to think that it was just a a just a weather balloon.
They flew the fucking wreckage in two separate planes and Eisenhower met them
there.
They flew it to Wright Patterson air force base.
And the reason they flew it in two separate plans because they didn't want the
plane to crash and then lose all the information.
So they,
they put,
they separated it into two planes just to make sure that they got some,
some of it got there,
dude.
They were so worried about plane crashes.
They sent two planes and that was what that Jesse Marcel guy had said,
right.
Or W who is the,
uh,
the,
the rancher was the ranchers name that discovered it.
To be honest with you.
I don't you don't remember the names.
No,
it's a,
it's a really fascinating story folks,
because the people that were there have like all these crazy stories of what
went down.
Some people saw bodies and there was one guy who was a local corner and they
asked him to actually make some,
um,
some coffin,
some small,
three foot long coffins.
And he thought there was some dead children and they,
uh,
they brought him,
they wanted,
he will,
you know,
they,
they have these things there and they were rotten and stinking supposedly,
but me,
it sounds ridiculous,
but so do we.
We sound,
we're just the fact that we're doing this fucking podcast,
this is ridiculous.
We're sitting here,
we're talking and somehow or another are talking gets broken down in a ones and
Zeros and sent through the air.
I'm not even connecting anything.
This fucking thing is wireless.
It is magic.
It's nuts.
It's craziness.
Just that is absolute fucking craziness and right now thousands of people are
listening and by the time they sent the whole thing is over be somewhere around
a half a million people have been contacted by these words coming out of our
mouth.
That's nuts.
It totally is because you know if you look at the the the status coincides and
all of this,
you know everybody's about physics,
this,
physics that but if you think about it,
physics and Newtonian physics that we apply to our physical world right here do
not apply on a subatomic level which is quantum physics.
Newtonian laws of physics do not apply at all in quantum physics.
What you're saying is well for folks who don't know there was a finance said it
best.
If you think you understand quantum physics,
you don't understand quantum physics exact cause.
Nobody understands it.
Well I shouldn't say nobody understands it cause there are,
there are certain things that we have figured out and discovered an under
certain things that we know but there's some madness in re like what has been
proven.
It's in,
it's all mathematically,
which makes no sense to me because I'm an idiot.
It comes to math.
I am literally a monkey.
Same here man.
But what they have figured out is that there are particles that can exist in a
super position where they were moving and still at the same time.
And then things blink in and out of existence.
Like they literally aren't there anymore.
And then they come back,
they go away and then they come back nature of reality or you have one particle
and you've got a cardboard thing with two holes and before you know it,
you look away and to particle finds itself on the other side of those two holes
really,
or one hole or two particles go through.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's this,
uh,
you know,
someone actually explained to me that whole thing about the,
um,
the results changing once you measure them,
that the observer changes the results.
Exactly.
But what do you mean sent it out?
This is WIC,
that friend in the movie or a documentary called what the bleep do we know?
See,
I,
I've,
I put that up online.
I'm glad we had this discussion because there's a lot of fuckery when it comes
to that.
That was all a created by the same people who did the secret.
And it's like those,
it's that lady who's like,
uh,
you know,
I'm talking too much.
She's like some sort of cult type lady ramp,
you know,
talking about,
okay,
yes,
what the bleep do we know?
And through the rabbit hole and all that stuff,
there's,
there's some fuckery to what they're saying.
And here's,
here's one of the parts of it.
It's not that the results change is because someone's looking at it.
It's because you're measuring it.
And so they've decided to make something really woo woo,
which is quantum physics is crazy.
Woowoo enough as it is.
They tried to add some sort of a mystical spiritual element to it that secure
controlling it with your mind.
I'm doctor Quantom.
Um,
you know,
I don't think that's correct.
According to My friend Wick,
Aka j d,
um,
he,
he said that it is all which totally makes sense and that this is something
that's really frustrating to actual real physicists.
That these,
these sort of ridiculous,
uh,
interpretations of physics that are,
expressed really inaccurately,
almost on purpose to make people think that there's,
you know,
that the secret is real.
The secret,
by the way,
may be real if you're a winner and if you succeed then the secret trail,
but guess what?
You get hit in the head by a fucking media or you didn't ask for that bitch.
Okay?
You're not really controlling the whole ball of wax.
That's ridiculous.
You can't really create,
reality is some randomness is experience.
You can certainly affect certain things.
You can certainly with positive energy affect your,
your immediate environment,
you know,
by creating good feelings amongst friends and things like that.
But you got controlling asteroids,
bitch,
you know,
they're coming and they killed the dinosaurs 65 million years ago.
Maybe,
maybe,
and they might've killed people off a 12 point 9,000 years ago.
Have you heard this?
This is a,
some of the latest data that's coming out.
And I felt like a bad mother fucker cause I sent this to John Anthony West and
he had not heard it yet and I was like,
yeah bitch,
I am your portal to new information.
I got it through Twitter,
some tweets,
which is the coolest shit about Twitter.
You know,
someone will send you like cool shit that you,
I mean I find out more cool shit through Twitter than anything.
Now Twitter and my message board,
those are the two things,
but 12,000,
900 years ago,
they know that there was some massive meteor impacts all over the planet.
They've confirmed it now by the,
um,
the um,
uh,
different parts of the world have this sort of,
glass that's created from incredible heat and impacts.
Yup.
They have some from the atomic energy sites,
you know,
where,
where we tested nuclear explosions and created it.
Well,
they've also found this
stuff and it's all at 12,900 years old.
When they do like core samples and the date,
the date,
the time of it,
it's all to 12,900 which is really fascinating because that's when all the
people that believe that there was some ancient civilization that was far more
advanced than we give them credit,
like ancient Sumeria,
Mesopotamia and ancient Egypt.
The idea is that 12,900 years ago,
there was probably already a hugely advanced culture.
Like we just assume that this tiny amount of space between 12,900 years ago and
today,
which is in the galaxy is again,
it's nothing.
We may have had to start over 12,900 years ago.
We may have been bombarded by giant pieces of rock from the sky that killed off
a huge amount of people and we had to start from scratch literally as hunter and
gatherers.
We literally had to do it like a fucking Kevin Costner movie.
Like we're like the post man.
I mean that's really possible that at one point in time there were some really
incredibly sophisticated societies.
And one of the things that's evidence is some shit that you brought me right
here.
The Age Blah from Puma poon coup.
He brought me a replica of a,
a real stone that exists.
You want a mind fuck on a much larger scale.
Of course,
that's just,
Oh of course.
Yeah,
this is fine.
But it's,
but it's incredible just to look at it as a tiny thing to thank.
If an ancient civilization created this,
like what kind of amazing machinery did they have to cut out these right angles?
Cause this really is representative of the actual stone structure.
You want a mind fuck folks go.
Um,
there's video on demand.
If you have that shit and you can get ancient aliens,
watch them.
The most recent one,
the Puma punk who one episode in season four?
Yes.
The mysterious city of Puma,
Puma [inaudible] mind.
Fuck that places.
It really is because I think that,
what's the altitude 12 almost 12,800 feet.
So that is,
you know,
an,
an altitude altitude where the air is already very rarefied.
Um,
you know,
you get tired real quick when you run around up there and you have this giant
field of ruins with these giant stone platforms that way,
or they start at like 80 tons,
these platforms and you know,
when archeologist or when you ask archeologists,
how did they move these giant stone platforms,
they'll say,
oh,
no problem.
They used wooden rollers.
And of course the entire world goes,
okay,
plausible idea,
plausible explanation.
And,
uh,
the truth of the matter is that a 12,000,
800 feet,
you're above the natural tree line.
So no trees ever grew at that altitude.
And so if you then propose,
all right,
so they went to a lower altitude,
got all the logs up there and use it then for wooden rollers,
if you only put a two ton block on top of a wooden roller,
the roller breaks.
So,
you know,
the whole idea of wooden rollers
and you know,
stuff like that,
it's just the rollers to go for 20 tons.
What is the biggest block at Puma Puma?
Uh,
one stands at 125 tons.
And just for reference,
fucking Christ
one ton is 2000,
200 pounds.
So you do the math.
I can't do the math that hurts my head.
Exactly.
A hundred tons.
And that's not even in,
you know,
in,
in Baalbek Lebanon,
we have a stone that's 1000,
250 tons.
What else?
Fuck.
Heliopolis and it's not on the floor.
It's on actually the third level of,
uh,
of,
of stone stone rose.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
and we're being told that our ancestors did this allegedly with chicken bones
and with dental floss.
So know I do agree with,
with,
with two ideas.
Either it had to have to do with extra terrestrials,
not that the extra terrestrials themselves build it,
but that our ancestors had help from them.
That's the big differentiation between the theory of the idea.
So even if they had a super advanced civil war,
he was a super civilization.
Exactly that.
Then somehow by media rights or whatever got wiped out.
So what we need to wrap our heads around those.
If it was a super advanced civilization,
it was really more advanced than us.
Oh sure.
When you look at their actual construction methods and what they could do when
you know,
you look at that,
just just what we know,
they have dated very accurately,
the construction of the Pyramids to 2,500 BC.
There are really positive about that.
It's,
you know,
taken all these different samples from different parts of it.
So just back then,
just back then,
2,500 fucking years ago,
something existed,
some sort of technology that allowed these motherfuckers to calculate so
perfectly,
they could put 2 million,
300,000 stones,
all of them coming to a point,
the covered and smooth lines to what the fuck were they using?
Right.
What the fuck are these guys using?
We don't have a clue.
We literally don't have a clue.
So for us to wrap our heads around the idea of like,
well that's preposterous.
Why would you think that aliens had something to do with it?
Because even if they were an advanced civilization that were wiped out,
they were way more advanced than us.
Like freaky shit.
Right,
exactly.
And I,
and I truly think that,
you know,
especially when you look at some of the ancient texts,
cause a lot of times the ancient alien theory is attacked for being,
you know,
uh,
one way of undermining human ingenuity.
And in a way I understand the,
the,
the upset.
But at the same time,
what I always say is,
look,
if we were to subscribe to the ideas that our ancestors wrote on paper or you
know,
I had in their oral traditions or whatever else,
then they themselves actually said that they did have help.
And for us to say today
they did that,
they did it all themselves because they even said that they had help.
You know,
who's really insulting whom here because you know,
they're saying the gods came from the sky and they all speak of things like the
Nephilim or the Anakie and it's always someone came from the sky.
But it could have been so bad.
Motherfuckers that lived in the other part of the world that had,
they had spaceships are ready and they were flying around earth and space ships.
Could that,
you know,
is that possible?
Like like make a an airplane,
not a spaceship and an airplane that looks like a flying saucer.
Could we do that today?
Probably red bull people have seem to do it.
Or maybe just like some super advanced dudes would come down and maybe you know
there was like one of those things where people go to the Amazon,
I go,
this is a TV,
you know like cause that,
because that happens today that go to the Amazon and they'll still apparently
according to Sam Sheridan did he say they still have uncontacted tribes when he
was,
he had spent some time in the ambulance and he said there was few.
So I don't,
I don't know if they were 100% sure about that because I had recently read about
one that they contacted that was a hoax.
There has to be done.
I mean it's,
it's a big,
those pictures that came out about three years ago where the helicopter window
with the tribe and they tried to hit hit the,
the helicopter was spears.
Yeah.
They were always all,
it was all pretty considerate.
Painted red.
Yeah.
They look dope.
It was your volume.
But I mean,
but this whole idea you see is based on what ethnology is referred to as a cargo
cult,
where if a technologically primitive society gets in contact with a
technologically advanced society,
that technologically Primitive Society perceives that technologically advanced
society as being God's,
God's,
which they're not.
I mean they're only from a perception standpoint,
gods,
but not really from an actual stance.
So real mind,
fuck is that gigantic Mayan statue that's carved of a dude in a spaceship.
I mean this month is slab.
If you haven't seen this in [inaudible] Bay,
there's this huge,
I guess what would you call it?
Mural?
It's,
no,
it's,
it's a sarcophagus list.
Yeah.
It's a lid.
A Lid.
Exactly.
But it's all carved in one giant piece of stone apps.
Yes.
And it,
the image is a man who is in a like an astronaut seat before you continue
through every bus.
Anybody can go online and just type in Palenque k slap,
So while we talk about it,
you should check it out because you're,
you're looking in my opinion at a,
at some type of,
of uh,
an aerial vehicle.
Yeah.
The guy is,
he's working pedals folks.
He's got it,
he's got a shift lever or something and it looks like he's looking through
optics.
It's like,
or he has some type of a breathing thing attached to his,
knows something's going on,
something's going on.
And he is reclined like in the same position like modern day astronauts when
they launch into space.
Yeah,
there reclined and uh,
he's wearing some really bizarre clothes and
on the outside you see this,
he sits insight.
This contraption that looks like almost like a bell shape and the at the bottom
of it,
if you look closely on one end,
at the bottom of this machine,
there is as if there's a carving that looks like and then exhaust flame or
something like this.
And it's fascinating and archeologists are interpreting this as um,
you know,
king precall on his journey to the underworld and things like this.
And Linda Sheely right before she died,
she did,
uh,
she translated the glyphs,
the band of glyphs that's around the slab,
uh,
in the sixties and seventies.
She translated as king per Carl's journey to the underworld.
And you can see how is swallowed up by the underground monster and things like
this.
But before Linda died,
she said that I would like to change my opinion about one translation I made and
she made a few changes,
but one that she was very particular about,
she said that she made a mistake by suggesting that this was king per Kyle's
journey into the underworld because she said that the word she baba,
which is underworld,
can have two meanings.
And the second meeting she said,
which he is more convinced about is the word Milky Way.
So what we have five George.
And so what we have here is a depiction of King [inaudible] journey to the Milky
Way.
How amazing is that?
So,
you know,
in one way the ancient alien theory has set this all along.
That what we're looking at here is some type of a vehicle,
uh,
some shuttle craft with which to go to the mothership or whatever,
or an actual spaceship.
Who knows,
right?
Because one thing I would like to make very clear,
none of these things that we look at today,
the pyramids,
uh,
the,
the [inaudible] that we're looking at here,
none of the ancient archeological sites,
none of that stuff.
Please.
None of it was built by aliens.
It was all built by human beings.
There's absolutely no question in my mind.
But as the ancient,
uh,
our ancestors said it was all built,
most of it,
the great majority was built with the help of the gods.
There in lies the difference.
I have never said,
you know,
that hey,
they,
aliens built the pyramids.
It's total nonsense to suggest such a thing.
Of course he was humans who did it,
but they themselves said that we've had help and he was this magical stuff that
they gave us with which we were able to move to stones and things like that.
So,
and,
and we're looking at it from a modern day perspective and,
and see,
you know,
what were they really trying to tell us?
It's a real good point that you made about people saying that,
you know,
you don't give enough credit to human ingenuity and that,
to really give credit to these people,
you have to listen to what the fuck they said.
Exactly.
And if there's a lot of photos or excuse me,
uh,
paintings from ancient times that show and like classic ancient paintings that
show people in what looks like a flying fucking spaceship.
Absolutely.
And you know,
to me the whole thing is,
is absolutely it's,
it's,
it's almost,
I mean,
not almost,
but it is insulting because we have to remind ourselves that when writing was
invented for the very first time,
imagine for yourself,
Joe,
for a moment in all of our listeners,
imagine if you've never,
if,
if you've lived now 30 years of your life,
but in all those 30 years he didn't know how to write.
And then all of a sudden overnight you learn how to write.
What's the first thing you're going to write down?
You're going to write down your name,
you're gonna write down your wife's name,
you're gonna write down your kid's name when they were born,
this and that.
And then after that you will tell other things that happen to you that were
significant.
So you're not going to lie in your first ever recording of,
uh,
you know,
knowing how to write.
It's possible.
But it's also possible that people have always been full of shit.
And as soon as they figured out how to talk to figure,
you know what,
I don't have to tell the truth and get in trouble.
Why?
Just make some shit up.
Dot is that is correct.
But as,
and I'm sorry,
I'm hearing some weird like crackling.
Do you think that's my headset?
It's like it's not connected,
right?
Or something.
It feels like maybe I,
maybe it's off.
Is it connected right?
No.
Now it's kind of like some crazy noise.
It's got a yes.
Yeah.
Let me see if maybe it's not connected over here.
I'm sorry.
What were you in the middle of saying?
Oh No,
that,
you know,
writing at at the back in the day was a new invention and so I disagreed at our
ancestors that all they did was sit around a campfire,
smoking dope and getting drunk and coming up with fantasy stories because every
psychologist and psychiatrist will tell you that no idea can come about without
a spark of inspiration and you know,
you doing your acts and stuff,
you know,
you're always inspired by stuff that's happening in your life.
If nothing would have happened in your life,
where would you get your material from?
Material from if you were to live in a vacuum.
So that's what they're suggesting is that these ancient stories,
especially the further we go back in time,
that the likelihood of them being nonsense or figments of our ancestors
imagination are very,
very slim.
That they actually saw something that's so far superseded their technological
frame of reference,
that they tried to describe stuff,
what they saw with the words they knew,
they didn't have the vocabulary to describe an actual spaceship with.
It's uh,
you know,
airlines and,
and whatever those names are.
And Airlines.
Well,
the um,
how do you call the,
uh,
it's on the back,
a w of the wing of planes.
Ailerons Stanson ailerons day.
They make the plane go up and down.
They don't have the specific jargon for these specific things.
So then they look at that stuff and because the Aileron is moving,
they think,
holy crap,
that thing must be alive.
And then they turned this whole thing into a bird or something like this.
And so all of a sudden we have birds.
Made of metal in ancient texts that make a lot of noise when they fly around.
But what's a one of my favorite passages from the Bible?
One of my favorite,
what the fuck pastures is the whole depiction by Ezekiel?
Yes.
Of the wheel within a wheel.
This fly he's talking about like what is the actual dino,
do you know the actual quote cause oh no,
no,
it's not an actual quote.
It's actual quote from the box versus upon versus it's a,
it,
it goes on and entirely through the,
there's the,
there's two books to the book of [inaudible],
first part and the second part.
And in the first part is he killed,
describes this thing that he sees,
not while he's asleep,
but while he's actually awake.
And,
uh,
it descends in front of men.
He refers to it as the glory of the Lord.
And he says that,
you know,
as it approached,
it was as if he was hearing a thousand waterfalls and the earth shook and the
wind and sand came into the air and the,
there was an earthquake and just,
you know,
he was trembling and he fell to the ground in awe because he was being visited
by quote unquote God.
And um,
you know,
it basically,
my,
the question then is,
since when would god need a vehicle to get from point a to point B?
And of course this is straight out of star trek five,
the unknown country.
You know,
where the idea was,
why would god ever need a via Colby?
God can create things,
but he actually still has to walk around.
You know,
maybe he's like totally bad ass,
but you know,
he can't like fly or anything.
Exactly.
Needs to make a spaceship.
Now what's really cool about the whole is equal story is that this NASA
scientist by the name of Joseph Bloom,
Rick,
he wrote a book called a space,
a space ships of Ezekiel in which there's NASA scientists.
This rocket scientist,
he looks at the biblical passages in the book of Ezekiel and he went to the
drawing board and he actually created this upside down cone shaped,
you have pho type flying saucer.
But how can he do that from those depictions?
Cause if depictions are so cryptic,
well of course,
and that is why,
you know,
he actually approached this whole idea trying to debunk Eric fun.
Danny can,
uh,
at a lecture that Eric gave in Huntsville,
Alabama at the NASA,
the NASA headquarters expert explained people who don't know Eric von Danna,
Ken,
he's came up with that,
the book and the movie chariots of the Gods.
And that was in the 1970s.
And,
uh,
you know,
viewers off the ancient alien theory recognize Eric with the gray hair and the
blue suit.
That's Eric [inaudible].
And he basically launched the whole ancient alien craze in the 70s.
And,
um,
you know,
there was a bit of a lull,
sort of the 80s into the 90s,
and we own a business and now it's booming kids.
Well,
you know,
but it's just fascinating that,
he is still around and he has just completed writing book number 34.
Oh my God.
Chariots of the gods.
So you know,
anybody who says,
you know,
is he still around?
He's still alive.
Of course he is.
And he's a pro.
He's more prolific than ever before.
I mean writing 35 books.
What is the latest [inaudible] roller skates of the wizards?
How many,
how many books can you write about the same subject lamps up to God or whatever.
You know.
So,
you know,
to me it's just fascinating that,
this proves that this is not just something that he thinks I can just sell a
couple of books,
but he genuinely believes this stuff.
Otherwise he wouldn't,
I don't think you know that you would still do this after
44.
What have,
you would certainly do it if it was part of your culture and you know,
as part of your,
uh,
your social circle,
but you know,
he lives in,
you might not believe it.
He lives in Switzerland.
They're very anti Ufo over there.
So I believe he believes it.
I mean I'm not necessarily sure that he's right,
but I believe that he believes it when I watch it though,
it's an amazing documentary still to this day.
It's incredible.
What's incredible about chariots of the gods is the shit that you cannot fuck
with.
I got in an argument when I first came to California and not an argument,
I was dressed down by a reporter character.
We were talking about,
uh,
you know,
a Ufo and somehow or another he asked me,
do you believe in Ufos?
And I always pretty much have said the same thing when I was younger.
I wanted to believe them for sure.
I said most likely they probably exist,
but who knows.
My,
my thing has always been who knows?
And uh,
he said,
well what evidence,
what evidence have you ever seen that makes you think that it's possible?
And I said,
well,
you ever see that movie charity,
the Gods,
they dude got so mad at me.
It was so funny.
Cause that's been deep.
Bunked are you kidding me?
Are you a child with your information?
And I was like,
what?
What has been debunked about those monsters structures that we can recreate
today?
What,
what has be debunked about,
you know,
but people don't,
even my,
my wife went to a college for She Greek history and that was her major.
And so she's fascinated by like ancient Greece and shit.
She was talking about the Acropolis,
the Parthenon,
right.
What people don't understand about the Parthenon is the top one,
right?
Yes.
It's built on the Acropolis.
The Acropolis is fucking monster stones that no one even bothers to explain.
They're just,
ah,
yeah,
some they were,
it was already there.
You just walk up it and people don't even realize what they're walking by.
You are walking by something that's impossible.
Like you,
you are stepping on something that's impossible.
It's sacred ground.
Just like Heliopolis in Lebanon or Bowel Beck.
Yeah.
You know,
they consider it a Roman temple today,
but you know,
the Romans only took over after the Greeks and after the Greeks to over and so
on and so forth.
And uh,
you know,
they don't know it's the biggest Roman temple outside of the Roman empire or
outside of Rome.
And the question is,
shouldn't the biggest temple I've been in Rome,
and the truth is that it wasn't because they knew what happened at Heliopolis
thousands of years ago.
It was sacred.
It's a sacred space like the Acropolis were allegedly a long time ago,
Zeus himself to send it from the sky.
She zoos also descended from the sky at Heliopolis in Lebanon.
So it's so fascinating that we have all these similar stories that all day back
to about the same time.
The bottom line is if you watch that movie,
if you look at,
you know,
the chariots of the gods,
the book,
if you look at any of these structures that you brought up,
this Poma punk who there's some fucking questions,
man.
They are some,
you cannot say that this is an a mystery.
No,
this is a mass.
And especially,
especially if we,
if we are to believe what the archeologists are doing that a block of stone,
like this was a,
you know,
cut with copper tools or with chicken bones and then they pulled it with dental
floss.
You know,
we have to also remain within the realms of physics.
You cannot cut a granite stone with a chicken bones or with a copper tool or a
bronze tool,
especially this per these perfect right angles.
It's completely flat and smooth.
Oh.
If you go and touch them with these edges and you apply a little bit of pressure
and you lower your thumb or your finger,
you can cut yourself.
That is how sharp those edges are.
And this,
by the way,
thousands of years after they were made,
yes,
thousand thousand.
Sure,
sure.
We're talking,
I mean,
everybody's,
in my opinion,
we're talking at least 12 to 15,000 years.
Even though the neighboring site,
which is only 250 yards away from Puma,
Pimco is Tiwa.
Norco to knock was a world famous site in every day.
Tourists arrive there.
They'd take pictures of the Gateway of the son,
of all those different places,
uh,
or or artifacts.
But nobody has told and only 250 yards away,
it's an even bigger mystery.
Puma Punko.
Now,
there are thousands of glyphs that were found,
hundreds of glyphs that were found at [inaudible] that have been translated.
And they all say that this place exists to,
and aqua exists only because of the events that happened at Puma,
Puma.
So it's a monument with God's descending from the sky.
It's a monument.
It's a place of pilgrimage and according to those translations of whatever is on
the backside of the Gateway of the sun,
that significant event are you guys ready for?
This happened 28,000 years ago.
But our are seeing stuff like this and they say our ancestors didn't know how to
keep records.
They didn't know how to calculate their years.
They made mistakes,
this and that,
like Noah was 600 years old.
Right,
right,
exactly.
And so that is why,
you know,
uh,
we cannot pay any credence to,
you know,
our ancestors.
You'd be no was on HGH.
Don't let,
no,
maybe no,
it took vitamins and just went straight Jacko lane on.
But this is the exact,
you know,
insult to our human ingenuity that I'm talking about because here we have these,
this giant,
you know,
gateway where someone or some artists painstakingly,
you recorded this date and here we are today saying,
you didn't know what the hell you are doing.
Yeah,
that is,
it's very insulting to say that these people didn't know what they were talking
about,
but yet they were able to complete something that literally we can't do today
and mailing out when you say,
Ooh,
yeah,
you broken.
Stop saying literally they can't do that.
Do you know what kind of a monumental fucking construction company you would
need to move a 1000 ton block bitch to cut and move 1000 tons.
Our,
our cranes today,
Peter out,
and um,
I might be mistaken,
but somebody told me this,
they Peter out at 1,350 tons,
that's,
and they're done.
And you know,
having that,
having that bell back stone or,
or having that,
uh,
you know,
cornerstone at Heliopolis,
that thing weighs 1000,
250 tons.
So w you know,
we're only 100 pounds,
I mean 100 tons off.
But the thing is that this thing was created at least 8,000 years ago.
And so,
you know,
to be told that this was all done with wooden rollers,
man,
if it was a hundred years ago,
imagine if we were told 200 years ago before the steam engine,
because we have
no steam engine was more than 200 years,
right?
It's been a few hundred years.
So let's go 500 years ago.
Could you imagine if we found out 500 years ago they did this?
They'd be like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
And see and,
and that's,
that's the,
the thing to me that,
you know,
how can you even suggest such a thing?
Because,
you know,
it's tricky because we have records,
but our records are really shitty.
You know,
like just looking at what we know,
like we still stuffed,
fucking just celebrate Columbus Day.
This is why right now it's not,
here's a water Bob behind your laptop.
It just fell over.
Did it really?
Jesus man's man,
you could ruin my new Alienware.
Laptops are telling the aliens would come down and fuck you out.
It'll be replaced by an alien thing.
I know,
but here's the thing that you know about us not keeping good records.
We can't keep records,
good records today.
So how the hell did they do it?
You know,
to kill Kennedy years.
And here's the thing that a lot of people are freaking out right now,
but the whole 2012 phenomenon that you know,
in a 21st of December,
2012 [inaudible] world is gonna end.
It's all bullshit,
man.
I'm just closing right now.
It's not even
2012 our calendar is off by at least a hundred years.
But that's,
you know,
before I delve into this a hundred at least at least,
and I'll give you the arguments in Islam,
not to Leo.
Zoe tries to,
no,
you're,
you're months,
your months and your birth month is fine.
Just not the year.
But the Mayan never suggested.
Not once that at the end of their calendar,
the world will end.
That's all,
you know,
modern new age bullshit.
This is my thought.
There's a lot of people that just love believing and like events that events are
coming love,
like predicting things and the people that seem to be really into this are
people that feel like society cannot evolve.
It has to be taken down and then we have to rebuild the society.
Like a community,
basically a lot of hippie cult type people that are looking to fuck your wife,
right?
Survivalists and shit because with the thing is all always that they only said
that a cycle of time will end and after a calendar and when a calendar ends,
what's next?
A new period of time.
A new cycle of time begins afterwards and so that is exactly what will happen
because the Maya,
they essentially had knowledge of a process called precession.
Precession basically means that the earth is at a certain angle on it's,
but this access that it's on,
it wobbles.
It makes this big wedding while it's spinning folks,
there's a 26,000 year cycle where it wobbles just sort of like a top,
you know,
or anything else.
It doesn't,
it's not absolutely perfectly in the way.
It's exactly,
and because the 2012 phenomena is fantastic,
are interesting is because that waddled this rotation returns for the first time
in 25,600 years to its point of origin.
Now once that happens,
which will be,
you know,
soon,
uh,
what's going to happen is this wobble.
This has procession cycle going to stop.
Of course,
not you.
It'll continue just like at the end of each,
each year on the 31st of December,
the following day,
it's January 1st.
That is the same thing with the Mayan calendar.
The world will not end.
There's no fucking judgment day.
There's no fucking apocalypse there.
No fucking,
you know,
Jesus coming down in a fucking cloud.
But what I think is in is,
and what have you are so wrong.
What if on December 21st you wake up the fucking skies on fire,
Jesus is on a surfboard.
Rollerblading.
Yeah,
man.
What if you're wrong?
How can you be so confident that it's not going to end?
The world could end for you,
right?
When you walk out this door,
you get hit by an asteroid cramp,
a crack,
open a beer and toasted Jesus on the surfboard man.
Cause imagine to offices came back and he was the silver surfer
fucking naked fly around telling people to love each other.
Yeah.
I think people recognize that this,
the way we're doing it right now is not going to be sustainable the way that
we're the ocean,
the way they were killing all the fish.
And I think people naturally look to someone to intervene.
Just like when you were a kid and you lit something on fire,
you like call dad because you want someone to come in and intervene.
And I think for a lot of people,
especially people that fancy themselves to be intelligent,
two intelligent for religion would like to believe in something.
So they go with aliens and they think that the aliens are going to come down and
somehow know that they're going to intervene.
And,
and so,
and I,
and I'm very set against that.
I think it's an actual disservice to this whole field.
Uh,
people who are propagating ideas like this.
I mean last or two years ago I was asked,
you know,
hey,
how come the aliens are not stopping the oil leak in,
in,
in the Gulf of Mexico?
And,
um,
you know,
how do you answer that?
It's like,
well,
because it was us who created,
you say,
well,
I was talking to them and say exactly that,
that crabs and shrimp and things are just a bunch of country animals and then
not really,
they don't care if they get fucked up by oil.
You know,
I mean,
the thing to me,
we can keep having cars.
The aliens are fine with it right now.
It's just so extremely bizarre to,
you know,
bank on the idea that to terrestrial was save us because,
or even Jesus.
Because the thing is that we all know inherently what's good and what's bad.
We all have a choice to make.
You either do the right thing or you did a wrong thing.
Whatever your,
your motives are,
but you know,
to,
to bank upon others,
to salvage the situation is nonsense.
It's a child is selling.
It's a childhood thing.
It's a thing.
You know,
again,
looking to someone older and smarter,
yes.
Care of your mess.
Exactly.
You know,
um,
but it's,
it's kind of a weird thing that we want,
we want to be rescued by a daddy.
Daddy's a god or daddy's an alien.
Daddy ain't coming.
But my question is what,
uh,
what do you think about these different stories about UFOs hovering around
nuclear test facilities and that shutting a powered down at certain places,
stopping missile tests and things along those lines.
Do you believe in those stories?
Like I said earlier,
you know,
I don't follow the modern Ufo field very closely,
but you know,
the nuggets that are important,
this is definitely one of them where you know,
there are,
you know,
certain catastrophes that have happened lately and you would actually see that
right beforehand there would be some type of UFO activity.
Now of course,
you know,
with today's Photoshop technology you have to be very cautious in this day and
age.
You know,
what you can subscribe to and what you think might be an actual hoax.
And so,
you know,
not everything is positive with our,
computer developments.
And things like this.
Um,
but the fact that you have full activity has turned off nuclear power plants is
not a an idea or an uh,
a rumor.
There have been military documents from
the 60s that have been recently released that have recorded exactly such a
events and that's quite fascinating.
Yeah,
it's quite fascinating.
They would come and let check these fucking monkeys out.
Imagine if we went to the Congo and we found some champs and they had figured
out how to make guns.
We were like,
what the fuck are you doing?
What the fuck are you doing?
These chimps are,
oh no,
no,
Nah Bitch,
Naw Bitch.
We would tranquilizer and we would take their guns and we would take the really
smart ones that figured out that make guns and we probably put them in a zoo
somewhere.
Exactly.
We,
we would,
we would definitely not let that happen.
And the idea is that maybe it's really fucking super hard to get to earth and
maybe they only come like really rare.
It just seems a long gap for us a few thousand years.
But for them it ain't shit.
You know,
it's possible that if you've will know,
because if you,
uh,
if,
if you fly as if,
if they have that type of propulsion technology,
if you fly,
for example,
at a very close to the speed of light at 99% or 9.9% of the speed of light,
then if five years elapse on your spaceship,
5,000 years elapse on earth,
this phenomenon,
anyone can go online and check it out.
It's called a time dilation phenomenon.
And this is automatic.
Yes.
And it's a mathematical fact.
So just imagine because we have ancient stories of these gods that lived in,
Ain't before the Egyptian Pharaohs began with their dynasties.
This is all pre dynastic stuff where we have certain kings ruling 56,000 years
and it's actually the,
uh,
the Wy which just keeps coming back pitch.
What did I tell you?
Fix that shit.
Actually set them a monument.
I'll see in a couple of thousand years.
Sam,
imagine you know that this,
this colon called King or space traveler is on a spaceship for 15 years.
And you know,
saunters around the universe and does something else.
And then after 54,000 years have elapsed on earth,
well he basically ruled for 54,000 years because he never abdicated before he
left.
So that is just,
I mean,
it blows your fucking mind when you look at these ancient texts and you're like,
what would a really,
yes.
Wow,
that is crazy.
Is it possible that someone could eventually figure out how to let something go
the speed of light without killing everybody inside of it?
And when they hit a bird,
they thought this,
when are you going to speed of light and you hit a bird?
I mean,
you're not going to be,
there'll be pulverized,
you're not going to be able to dodge birds.
But you question about,
you know,
how could you go at this speed without being crushed?
The asked the same question when they created cars.
Well,
how about when the created trains they thought weren't training.
If you go 30 miles an hour would kill you.
That's what they really thought.
Much five and a plane,
you're fine.
Any is newer environment and uh,
you know,
could you imagine getting a dude from like
the 18 hundreds of thought?
You're going to die in a train and putting them in a corvette.
She started ready,
but
just looking at the miles an hour.
He,
if you brought a corvette,
if you could bring a corvette like a thousand years ago,
people would,
they'd be like,
God
under God,
ups undergo which,
and they will kill you.
All the chicks would it blow you?
They would all blow you because no one else has a corvette.
I mean,
not only do you have a bad ass car either the only dude on the planet with a
car.
Okay,
chicks would SPI.
So on your jock don't know.
And it's,
and it's totally fascinating because that is exactly,
that's what happened.
That is the idea.
That's the cargo cult died.
Well,
I was thinking today I was,
I was driving in as I often do when I'm in traffic in La,
that the only way you can really keep people in line is if you don't let them
fly around.
Because as soon as you can imagine,
if we would have flying cars by now,
dude,
there'll be no borders,
borders and be done,
it will be death.
You'd have to have nets.
No,
no set up to keep people from flying over from Mexico like mile high net.
The population would be decreased by $100 million.
100 million people instantaneously really spread out.
Where would they go?
Or they would just crash and die because they wouldn't know how to handle
themselves.
If they were magnetized where they were like two magnets can't come off each
other,
then you put it on a flying cars and they're the maglev trains.
No,
they're flying cars with magnets in the front of them so they could never
actually touch.
Okay.
I'm always thinking,
learned to fix the society.
I'm trying to be a part of Shit.
Good thing.
The problem.
Well,
it seems to me if you,
um,
listen to the current theory,
like if you listen to,
um,
what does,
what does that one gentleman's name who's,
uh,
they always use him.
Stanton.
Freeman.
Yes.
Yeah.
He's a,
he's a clear physicist.
Physicist.
That's a big proponent of,
uh,
the possibility,
the reality of Ufos.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
he talks about magnetic propulsion systems at some sort of a magnetic wave could
be created,
magnetic propulsion systems could be like,
what is the outside area when you see like,
uh,
like the glow of the saucer,
what's really going on,
some sort of magnetic sort of a thing.
If that was a case,
that would be a way that you could keep from crashing into each other.
Like magnets can't touch magnets,
right.
Ms Obviously it's different type of magnetics,
but I would see if seems like,
if you can,
you know,
if you can use,
uh,
something and create some sort of a magnetic field,
you could possibly also use it to repel other spaceships.
No,
I agree.
We would stop all car accidents,
but I would,
I would s I would prefer if before having flying cars,
we now have to realize that we would be half a technology to build cars or in
car engines that run on water.
So before we do flying,
flying cars,
let's run our cars on water,
which as long as they still sound good,
you know,
they can put them.
I like the cartilage.
Sounds good.
I'll,
your car's got a little bass to it,
Paul.
I,
no,
it feels good.
It makes me feel American.
Want to listen to some fine.
There will be some company they will come up with it.
And uh,
well,
you know,
BMW is cheating right now and they're m fives.
I'm really disappointed.
BMW,
how dare you do this.
They switched over from naturally aspirated engines to turbocharged engines.
And when you do that,
you send forced air into the engine and,
and it,
it muffles the sound.
It doesn't give you that deep like v eight Shelby Mustang feeling blah.
They lose all that sound.
And so the latest m m m five the old one,
the last model,
which was an amazing car,
500 plus horsepower was a v 10.
It was a large nationally,
naturally aspirated engine,
but now they've switched over to turbochargers.
So because people love the sound like the old BMW m five was fucking glorious.
The sound that thing would hit when it hits red line.
It's like,
to me,
I may freak when it comes to engineering and technology.
I am absolutely fascinated by the automobile industry because although everybody
like likes to think of them as like,
it's like Frivolous,
Oh,
you have a nice car,
you know?
Oh,
you know,
you're fucking materialistic.
Oh,
I am celebrating cool shit that human beings have created.
And one of the coolest things that's going on in the world when it comes to
innovation is the automobile industry.
When you look at like high end automobiles,
like the,
the craftsmanship and intelligence that it's involved,
even if I couldn't afford a nice car,
I would still be fascinated.
I would always read those magazines just same way I read Gizmodo or uh,
you know,
uh,
we'll buy a copy of wired or end gadget.
I'm fascinated by the innovation.
I'm fascinated by the continual,
uh,
the need of d to improve things.
And when you see it in cars,
it's incredible what they're doing now.
But BMW unfortunately had to resort to cheating to make their car sound good.
So now it comes through the stereo.
There's a v eight sound that comes through the steroids that sync up with the
computer and the engine.
So as you're revving your car,
it's gone.
That's not real.
It's coming through your fucking stereo speakers
that told me that's a joke.
Please BMW.
How dare you?
Well,
you know Nissan doesn't do that with the GTR.
I,
I the GTR is one of the fastest cars in the world and it sounds like a fucking
spaceship.
It's a different sound that turbocharger Ooh,
it's a different sound,
but it's still fucking bad ass.
You got to accept the fact that this doesn't sound like a Va.
It sounds like a force induction car,
which may not have.
It's not as sweet and as like manly a note,
but it's still pretty fucking trippy.
You've got to accept what your car sounds like.
BMW.
I was actually,
when you're saying this story,
I was like,
oh,
the day there,
it's just not as loud anywhere.
I was like,
they shouldn't have it.
Go through this stereo.
So you think it is.
I was thinking that's what I fill up first.
That's what I,
how I understood it too.
Right.
And then it was like they're cheating.
That's,
that's worse.
Make noise,
you know,
worse than idea.
Yeah.
We thought,
well the Porsche,
the new Porsche,
um,
one of the things they've done with the nine nine one,
the palm,
I'm a huge fan of Porsche's and I know it sounds like such a douche bag thing to
say.
It's like,
oh,
you like Porsche.
You know what else you do?
Like,
do you like playing Polo?
You fucking queer.
You know,
it sounds like something like the privileged people,
but again,
I'm a freak for engineering.
I'm absolutely fascinated by technological innovation and cars have come so far
in my lifetime,
when I was a kid,
my first car was a 1973 Chevy Chevelle.
It was a piece of shit was a Chevelle ss.
I had it for one day and it wouldn't fucking start.
And I called the dude up and go,
man,
it's fucking car doesn't even start like,
what's wrong with this fucking car?
And the guy goes,
you can give back to me.
I'll give you your money back.
And I was like,
oh you knew it was a piece of shit.
You son of a bitch.
So I brought it back to him and he gave my money back.
But when you look at that and then you look at like a Porsche nine 11 like they
just released the newest one,
the nine nine one it's a technological masterpiece.
They have dual clutches now.
You know I prefer a manual gearbox.
I like shifting my own fears.
It's fun.
Mine has dual clutch is hearing your Volkswagen does as you're driving annual,
are you kidding me?
You shared with the paddles.
These paddles shift in like milliseconds.
It used to be that automatic sucked and the reason why you know you got a a four
speed is cause it was actually faster.
Five-Speed was fast,
six speed was faster.
But then somewhere along the line that's the automatics in like they caught up
to the the manual cars and then they surpassed him like greatly.
Now if like a manual Porsche is like 4.6 seconds,
zero to 60 but the automatic you can get that bitch down to like 3.9 3.6 because
they have this um,
this dual clutch that where you can have a launch control,
like you stop on the gas and it does it all with the computer.
You stop on the gas and just let off the brake and it just calculates the amount
of wheel spin controls.
It gives you the perfect amount of acceleration and it just goes like a fucking
Bat Outta hell.
They have a launch control and a Nissan Gtr,
which was like one of the most technologically advanced cars that humans have
ever created.
It's a car that they're actually losing money on selling.
It's such an incredible masterpiece of technology and they want in it to Nissan.
So they sell it for like a hundred grand and they lose money on each one,
but it's their flagship when it hit.
When you do launch control and the Nissan,
it brings you to 2.8 seconds,
zero to 60 in 2.8 seconds.
Wild.
Does it depend what surface you're on though?
Sure.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Of course you would like to be on a race track ideally where it's nice and
smooth and flat,
but you know,
it's,
it's an incredible masterpiece of engineering and what they've done with Porsche
at the combat,
the sound issue is they,
uh,
they just made a better fucking exhaust system.
That's how Germans rocket for the most part.
They didn't cheat like those other BMW assholes.
I just think it was it just a bad idea that someone,
someone talked them into doing their property.
That's horrible if true.
I mean,
I believe
it,
but that's just,
it just does not seem real.
Yeah.
No.
Well,
BMW in Germany,
that's Sturman do you read it all in or all local first year?
It's real.
The Porsche,
that solution is,
they have it.
I'm baffled that were the sound.
Uh,
there's like a,
a valve that they can open up or the sound like enters into the cabin more,
but it's a rich sounding exhaust note anyway,
they figured out how to do it the right way,
but that's a naturally aspirated car.
The new Porsche.
When you get into turbos,
you just got to deal with the fact that it's a different sound.
That's one of the coolest things about the,
um,
you know,
the,
the a Ufo is that people see that they,
they say they're fucking silent.
Like those ones that flew over Phoenix,
they say that,
you know,
this is gigantic triangle that's a flying through the air and it's completely
silent and you see like little glowing lights around the edges of it and shit.
Your pants,
cause it's as big as a football field.
Right.
Do you believe that the Phoenix lights story and all that shit?
It is a,
it's a different,
it's definitely an interesting story and I've seen the footage.
It's,
it's quite bizarre.
And the flares though,
right?
Couldn't it be fun?
Oh no,
because they didn't come down kind of hovered the way that the players would
come down and you know,
the whole Ufo field to me is why not.
Right.
It could be because you know,
I know personally that a lot of UFO stories or abduction stories or stories by
experiencers,
they're all made up.
A lot of them are made up.
I know some people that,
um,
have told me that they made stuff up and so first of all,
it's a huge disservice to the entire field.
And it's funny that you keep calling it a field.
Well,
it is a field of study,
I guess it is or topic when it comes,
when actually when the shit hits the fan and then Ufo or fucking for sure.
Really here then it's a field.
Yeah,
100% yeah.
But then still a field,
all the bunkers,
hilly field and then all the debunkers we'll say,
well,
we knew it all along,
but we just couldn't say something.
You think so you watch?
Absolutely.
Wow.
That's interesting.
Sure.
People like Erich von Daniken,
Zacharias,
Zechariah stitching will be left by the wayside.
So he's all this tumor ologists all the Egyptologists,
they're all,
Yo,
whoa.
We just couldn't talk about it.
Wow.
You really think that's what's going on.
Absolutely.
That'd be fucking fascinating.
Would be hilarious to watch.
It'd be hilarious to watch the mad scramble if we really saw actual UFO.
You believe it.
That's why it would be in my opinion,
I think pandemonium because I think people like you and me and red band and all
of our listeners,
you know,
they will be quite all right.
Cause you know,
you'd be crazy not to think that we're alone and um,
you know,
but I think the great majority of of mankind they would freak out.
Yeah.
Or what the aliens really are is the people that are keeping us trapped in the
simulation and that we live in some really boring ass fucking future where they
figured out how to make sex is not the way you make babies anymore.
Everything's done through replication and genetics.
They have orgasm pills
so nobody fucks.
Like in the,
in the uh,
judge Dredd Stallone version did that,
what they did in judge Dredd exactly like dad,
they devolve to aliens yet and the judge Dredd or evolve rather,
I know they have to think our big heads is troll shit telepathically and not the
big eyes cause anything can see the whole space.
You get to see you if my gear and everything is controlled with their minds.
So they got like shit for like physiques cause they don't care.
They're not trying to get laid.
You don't have to be all swol terrible.
You know,
aliens never tried to be yoked.
They don't give a fuck.
So what if the aliens are us?
It's like if you looked at us and monkeys,
okay,
we know for a fact that human beings were some sort of primate that was
initially different than it is now.
Okay?
That's pretty,
pretty much agreed upon by the evolutionary theorists that you know,
there's our [inaudible],
there was a bunch of different types of human beings,
and then homo sapiens emerged at one point in time.
Well,
whatever the fuck create what if you look it out?
We had to somehow or another,
we were something else at one point in time.
That's the whole idea behind the,
the idea of evolution.
And again,
I'm too stupid to understand whether or not evolutions real.
That's an entirely different argument.
Well,
even Darwin is,
look how much different we are than a monkey and aliens.
Not that much different than us.
Or You look at a gray alien with the big fucking almond eyes and the big head
and the fact that it has two arms and two legs and stands up,
it actually looks more like us than a gorilla does,
you know,
or a monkey with a tail,
or some of the other crazy primates that we know for sure.
A real,
if you look at a backbone and you look at a person and you look at a person,
you're looking at an alien.
I think an alien looks more like a person than about Boone does.
Right?
No,
I agree.
And that is why,
you know,
Darwin himself,
he suggested that,
uh,
you know,
he liked his own theory.
However,
in the end he had to conclude there was a missing link.
There was something that despite everything doesn't make sense,
and today's,
it's a hologram.
That shit ain't real.
Well,
we're in a simulation.
Giorgio,
we exist in a boring ass few.
Never say never.
You know,
I mean,
I,
I choose to disagree,
but we never say never.
Why do you disagree though?
I don't know.
I,
it's not high enough.
You're not high enough to be right here with got the ridiculous.
What if train is to opt to pockets?
What?
Tupac is our king
in this Hologram,
Hologram Tupacs running shift in the future.
He's really good at rhyming,
so they said,
listen,
you should be in charge.
You rhyme.
The fucking shit out of words.
Isn't that amazing that all you have to do is be like really good at talking and
people are like,
please keep talking.
How do you do it?
How do you keep rhyming things?
Biggie,
biggie.
Can't you see sometimes you wear,
they hypnotize me.
How does he do that?
He was alien.
Doesn't matter man.
Yeah.
That's the funniest meme online as you buddy.
Yeah,
all your,
I didn't hear the question but the answer is aliens.
What if you must love that though?
That is so bad ass.
It's awesome.
I mean how can you even not love it?
It's absolutely fantastic and some those memes that,
I mean they crack me up for real.
Even even the,
the,
the crappy ones.
I mean they're still there.
It's all funny because if you imagine people out there that are going through an
effort to,
to,
to write something and I think,
you know,
thanks.
It's cool.
Thanks to everyone.
Seriously.
I love fucking awesome.
There's a bunch of me about weed.
One of them was sometimes I don't smoke weed.
Yes I do.
It's,
it's,
they're,
they're awesome.
Mad.
The Internet has created some of the my favorite comedy of all time.
Even shit that's like really completely inappropriate and he shouldn't laugh at
10 was at one.
There were,
there's as this black guy that had his mouth open,
his eyes were bugged out of his head and he was surrounded by watermelons and it
said,
Oh Lourdes is I in heaven.
And I know,
I know it's rude and it's racist,
but I'm fuck I was crying laughing.
I was like that is wrong.
As fucked up.
But God damn,
that shit is funny.
Cause if you see the look on the guy's face is ridiculous and the fucking
watermelon.
So why is it racist to fucking say someone likes a delicious fruit?
I don't know.
Cause I love watermelon grape drink and everything.
How about chicken?
Chicken is delicious,
but isn't it fucked up that you can say like if say you chicken,
watermelon,
Eaton person,
you know,
they'll like that.
That's an insult.
You're an asshole.
You're racist.
Why black people?
Who's eating chicken?
Fuck you.
Well meanwhile chickens are delicious.
Yeah,
what's wrong with that?
Meat and chicken.
There's nothing wrong with that.
But if you say,
why are black people always eating chicken?
They're like,
man,
you're a racist bitch.
They get mad at you.
It's bullshit.
It is bullshit.
But it,
cause if you ask an Italian,
you know,
you post heat and motherfucker and Billy posture's pretty good.
Luckin was audience delicious.
You know what the fuck is wrong with you?
Like delicious food.
How sensitive are black people when it comes to their diet?
Well,
I don't know.
Italians are pretty sensitive though because they get mad.
Like you get mad at olive garden.
No,
no Italians.
There's a some weak ass bitch of times.
Just like there's weak ass bitch everything.
But you know,
like the people that were protesting about the soprano's that made me disgusted
and made me glad.
And I'm an Italian last name and he said,
I got an Irish last time,
like you'd dummies Italian American association that's a Pronto was on fairly
represents us into media.
You should fall New Jersey housewives pitch.
Okay.
That's when the Italians are really like,
fuck you.
There's plenty of them.
God Damn it though.
That's my people.
So I'm allowed to shit on them.
It's like a black people allowed to use the word nigger.
Like Chris Rock had that,
uh,
that bit the one of the greatest bits of all time and all comedy.
I love black people.
I hate niggers,
but that is a genius bit by Chris Rock,
what I,
my opinion,
top two or three,
all time bits,
any human being has ever created and he could get away with that.
Whereas Brian Red band would just get rocks thrown at them.
I had to do a,
my first kind of black room the other day,
I did that downtown comedy club and it's black rock.
It's not a black room,
but it's,
and it's like,
it's just people walking on the street going,
hey,
let's go see a comedy show.
So there were people there with their whole entire,
I don't know what that was.
It was German,
but uh,
but they sat in the front row tourists and shit.
Yeah.
They're all wearing like their suits and stuff.
Like they were like,
we're going out and seeing a live show.
Oh.
Because a lot of people like work there and those silos.
Yeah.
And so it was,
it was,
it was weird because they don't,
I don't know,
I feel like a disgusted them,
you know,
like they're talking about sex.
They were just like,
you have to understand that if people don't know you,
your gross.
Right.
Do you know that?
People love you if they know you well,
he's like,
listen man,
this is,
this is the way of the world.
You have to find your audience.
You know,
people right now,
people will come to see you and they love you because they hear you on the
podcast and because they,
they,
they like,
you're silly sense of humor.
But if they did know you,
they be like,
what the fuck is going on?
I mean,
there was one point,
there's a little older,
like a black lady,
like,
like pulled out a handkerchief and did the old like patting her forehead with a
handkerchief.
You're standing in front of strangers and you're talking about throwing your
sperm on hotel walls.
Meanwhile they're staying in a hotel and they're like,
oh fuck.
So they're not going back to the hotel.
In my head I was doing that bit that,
you know,
uh,
about the two or the three pets.
I have two cats and the dogs and I'm thinking in my head,
all right,
this is a clean bit.
You don't have to pop my cats and dogs and stuff like that.
And I'm like,
wait,
no it's not.
And
that's hilarious.
Well that's a funny bit though.
They got to just relax.
Stop being silly bitches.
They need to drink more.
I've been hanging out downtown a lot more trauma and it's,
it's neat.
Have you ever spent time,
like a lot of time downtown,
there's some of the best restaurants in la or downtown,
so the best bars are in town,
but what sucks is that it's like bar cool restaurants,
hot women and fancy people everywhere and then one block over you're going to
get shot and killed it.
Like it's just mixed up.
So there's no like spread out of like wealth and people.
It's just people mixed in like not enough class structure for,
you know,
I don't like poor people running around fucking up your fun.
I mean,
not just poor people,
like dangerous danger.
What people don't know about downtown La.
It sounds like what Brian's saying is like,
well,
you don't want to be around poor people.
Downtown la has skid row and if you haven't seen skid row,
it is real.
And skid row is a fucking huge street that's filled.
It's nice.
The streets like half downtown,
every single block,
every other block.
Well,
there's one big area though.
There's one main area where it is a,
it's a village of,
of homeless people.
It's incredible.
I mean,
you'd never seen anything like it.
You're talking about,
you drive down the street,
there's hundreds if not thousands of people and it's like a Zombie movie.
It's really crazy.
Really.
It's like,
I don't know if like there's areas where they let them do this and they don't
fuck with them.
And then there's like a place where they can go get food that's nearby.
And so like people were camped out in front of that.
Like it's,
it's,
we did a lot of fear factor down there and it's crazy.
He's not exaggerating.
It's like it's something where you go,
oh sure.
No.
What fascinates me is if you looked
at those people and if you look at the people that are just complete fuck ups
and they just can't get their shit together,
they're fucking losers.
And you stop and think about the possibility,
the,
what humans can accomplish.
What a person who builds a nuclear reactor can do with someone who's working at
cern.
The large Hadron collider is capable of,
they know the person who did the people rather who designed fighter jets and
drones and the Internet.
And then look at bumps and you go,
man,
people are weird.
What a fucking strange animal that vary so wildly.
And yet these things are all surviving.
Whereas if they were like [inaudible] chickens didn't lay eggs or didn't know
how to eat with their face,
they would be fucking dead.
You know,
they'd be,
that'd be gone.
Every chicken is like almost exactly the same.
I mean they vary so slightly,
but human beings,
fuck,
we vary wildly in appearance and wildly in our capabilities and our complements
and our adaptability to our reality and are the,
are the environments that we establish around ourselves,
the,
the community that were just wildly,
wildly different.
And one of the arguments that I've heard for the reasons for that is that human
beings are light dogs in that they look totally different,
but they can breed with each other,
which doesn't make sense and no,
no.
They're part of the animal world.
Like an elk can't fuck a deer,
you know,
they,
the main,
he could,
elk is run and shit.
You know,
elks are huge.
They want to fuck a deer.
They could,
but it's not,
nothing's going to come out of it.
But shack can fuck Bridget damage it and he could get her pregnant and they can
make a baby.
And that's legit.
That's real.
That only exists in the dog world.
And the reason why it exists is because we engineered dogs.
We made them out of one thing.
Dogs used to all be wolves.
We figured out somehow another,
which by the way,
if you pay attention to genetic engineering of dogs or the,
or rather the,
uh,
study of,
the,
the genetics of dogs,
they think that all dogs somehow or another came out of wolves and it happened
more than 10,000 years ago.
They don't know how the fuck it was accomplished.
I mean,
dogs are one of the biggest mysteries when you look at what is possible when you
take an animal and you turn it into something else.
The fact that up fucking chill.
What came out of a wolf.
Somehow they thought it was originally they thought it was going to be a bunch
of wild candidates,
a bunch of different kinds of canines that were,
that were created that that's how a dog was created.
And then there's all kind of bread together.
No,
no,
no wolves.
They all came from fucking wall.
He can ease if I'm out both from a wolf,
a fucking wolf.
Yeah,
no,
it's wild.
Absolutely crazy.
But that idea is that,
and for sure wolves rather turning into dogs that was engineered by people we
made that,
I mean they're,
they breed bulldogs.
They do it on purpose.
That is,
in my opinion,
one of the best pieces of support for the idea that human beings may have been
created,
that human beings may have been and said not a selection,
just due to,
you know,
a branching off in different climates,
established,
different,
you know,
different types of people.
Maybe not,
maybe not.
Maybe human beings were made.
Maybe we were created and not just once,
maybe it was several.
The ancient alien theory suggests,
yeah,
that's one of them.
You know,
the main tenants of the whole idea bringing the dog thing.
Uh,
we have brought it in not with the dogs but for example,
the leopard as an very interesting genetic history where the leopard just
basically appeared out of nowhere.
Uh,
and uh,
what's fascinating to me is that if we look at our history,
uh,
genetically speaking,
you know,
in any other species,
if a species reaches a certain point,
what a population dwindles down to such low numbers and there isn't enough
genetic material available in the,
in the gene pool,
then that species has reached a stadium that's called,
um,
the genetic bottleneck stadium where the genetic bottleneck effect,
meaning that if that should happen to any species,
then they are 100% guaranteed to die out.
So like an inbred dog.
Exactly.
We've all seen in,
but I have a friend who has an inbred dog and she doesn't want to admit it or
fucking dogs eyes are that far apart from each other.
Dog is stupid as shit.
And I go,
where did you get this dog?
She goes like a breeder,
one of the top breeders,
my top readers,
that dog,
that dog is brother fucked.
It's sister fucked.
It's baby fuck.
That is,
this is a terrible English.
And what's crazy is that,
like I said,
it's a mathematical certainty.
If I would species reaches that stadium and anybody can go look,
does online is not something that I came up with.
They die out period.
Right now there's one species on planet earth that has gone through two genetic
bottlenecks.
US human beings.
How the hell did we survive?
How do they know?
We went through two genetic bottleneck geneticists or have have researched it
and it's geneticists that have,
uh,
found the evidence for that apparently in Europe and it's been corroborated here
in the states.
So,
so,
you know,
to think about,
and this is why I'm saying that these two stages where that happened,
there's no way we could have survived without the guarantee by extraterrestrials
that they ensured our survival,
our breeders.
Yes.
We don't want to accept that idea as they're called in,
in,
uh,
prometheus's the engineer's.
Yeah.
Yeah,
we don't unaccept that idea,
but yet we do accept the idea that things will continue to improve of course,
but that does gotta mean it's going to go somewhere.
And so how do we know it hasn't already gone somewhere somewhere else?
Should I know,
to me there's much more evidence that we are arrogant and that we,
uh,
you know,
in the name of,
of science and calling things science and academia that we are refusing,
look at
the reality that this whole thing is a crazy mystery.
And that although there are some things that science has a absolutely 100%
proved and these are fascinating things and they should be credited for it and
thought scientists,
amazing.
And don't get me wrong,
that's not what I'm saying.
But what I am saying is everyone is a little bit fucking cocky.
And when you got to be sure 1000 stone ton stones laying around,
and when you got all these people that existed thousands of years ago drawing
shit on cave walls,
it looked like fucking aliens and spaceships.
And then these people who were really classic artists who actually could draw
what they were seeing and had people and seated positions with rocket ships
flying through the background of a classical like,
I mean,
it looks like a Victorian era painting and they have people flying around in the
fucking air.
Like what do they,
what do they depicting?
No end what we're saying.
Or not us of course,
but the mainstream archaeologists that that was nothing else but a figment of
our ancestors imagination that they had to put something on the walls in order
to make sense of nature.
Now what an insulting statement is that because our ancestors were a people of
nature,
they were so familiar with nature,
you couldn't even fathom how much they were in touch with nature.
So to say that they had to,
you know,
make sure to make shit up in order to make sense of nature,
in my opinion is total bull shit.
Okay,
I got one word for you then.
Ready?
Tell me dragons.
Dragons is the fuck dragons.
Uh,
you know,
that's,
that's another thing that I'll be addressing tonight.
My,
my,
Oh yeah,
let's everybody let everybody know about that because that is a,
if you want to see Giorgio in person,
you could touch his hair tonight,
tonight,
tonight.
Los Angeles here in Hollywood at the Universal Sheraton.
Everybody should come out and it's at 7:00 PM it starts and it's a long ass
lecture,
right?
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a two hour,
two and a half hour presentation with Q and.
A.
We're going to take pictures,
audit autographs afterwards.
I will show folks,
this is what you do,
everybody.
You got to flood this place and every time in the Q and a,
I want to be ready.
I was really going to ask olive garden questions.
Imagine it was,
the whole show is just assholes from this asking about all of gardens.
A drag.
I would love it.
The dragon dragons are not a fig Newton of your immigration or
no,
they're not.
No,
no fig Newton enough.
Your immigration.
I love that.
That's a good one.
It's hilarious that in the future,
um,
the nose like that upper is,
I go saying that Shit Bro.
Yeah,
that's a good one.
Um,
no,
but the thing is we have to ask ourselves with this idea of dragons come from,
because our ancestors were very,
uh,
like I said,
in touch with nature and for them to come up with a story like dragons is quite
bizarre to me because in many occasions of these stories,
uh,
those dragons have always been brought into a comparison with fire,
smoke and a lot of noise.
And exactly.
And because I say rocket ships or you say rocket ships and I agree with you
because whenever these dragons quote unquote landed,
the belly would open up and the gods would walk out of those dragons.
So if a dragon and every culture,
most,
yes,
most every in in India we have Garuda and uh,
you know,
the Vimana into vimanas.
And then in China and in Japan we have to dragons.
But most of the times,
and also in the Middle Ages,
in some of the European countries,
um,
we have these stories where the bellies would open up and that's where the gods
would walk out of.
And guns,
as we all know,
lower case g has nothing to do with the university,
Yada Yada.
So just,
you know,
cause gods do not exist the way it's also our,
our term for these things.
Like when you,
when you were transcribing Sumerian culture,
when you're transcribing their languages,
it's like there's a lot of it that is very abstract.
It's very hard to wrap your head around exactly what they're saying.
And there's a lot of translations that are really weird.
So the word God in our eyes,
you know,
we're saying it's a god,
we're saying that this is a god,
but it's very possible that their,
their word was a different word,
like the,
the Nephilim.
Sure.
You know,
people look at the Nephilim and they,
they,
they believe,
well,
what did it mean?
What is the,
the actual,
like if you wanted to talk to a mainstream biblical scholar,
what would they say?
The nephilim is supposed to represent the fallen angels,
fallen angels,
and they will pretty much,
that was the way to get away with inhabiting other gods other than God.
Well No.
And they were kind of like God's angels.
Yeah,
there's soup.
Well,
solar dope.
They were messengers between the gods and human beings.
And they weren't angels the way we would think of angels today,
that they're these ethereal beings that are invisible.
And you know,
there's a good one sitting on your left shoulder and a bad one on your right
shoulder and things like that.
So it's a,
you know,
angels also have never been depicted with wings until fairly later.
The,
from,
from the first times angels,
wherever even,
uh,
described or the word angel even came up.
I mean,
Angel comes from the Greek word of Anglos basic,
which means middleman or messenger.
Holy Shit.
You know.
So if we look at the electric we did that we need role do tongue on gallows.
Angulo suppose a check.
I'd be very,
very turned on by that formula.
So nationally and you know,
so,
so the thing is that,
you know,
the wings were only added later,
but why were they added it?
Because those messengers that were in touch with those gods had the capability
of flight and that flight never took place.
We stupid wings by it took place with some type of a technological machine.
And of course that is,
you know,
subscribing to the engineering
theory.
Chess,
some other people.
Yes.
Jetpacks now you watch that or if you um,
don't know if you have seen this,
these youtube clips of this dude that has his rocket pack.
Oh yeah.
But it's attached to the water with a long tube and it water shoots out of his
rocket pack.
And so he can be,
you know,
flying around on that thing for hours.
And if you look at that white water,
that ejection of that Whitewater looks like wings,
even though it's technology and he looks at things,
it looked like aliens are not going to use that stupid water thing.
No.
What I'm,
my argument is that if somebody watches this,
Ryan found having a technological frame of reference,
then they won't know that what they're looking at is a jet pack.
They will think it's something divine.
Well not only that is misunderstood technology.
Not only that,
but most likely every single depiction of any of these events was told as a
spoken word sort of a thing for a thousand years before it was ever written.
Exactly.
So when you,
you talk about the depictions in the Bible you are,
you are already talking about some really ancient shit anti and the Bible is not
even an owner,
an original work.
There have been at least six other books,
holy sacred books that were found before the Bible that also tell if a flood
story.
So the Bible is not the first sacred book.
In fact,
it's a very young book.
There are other books that go back to 6,000 years especially talking about the
new testament.
Exactly.
Oh literally know the people who chose what's in it,
Constantine and all these bishops and they put it together and the council of
Nicea and there was some shit they even left out like they were.
So those are called,
those are called the epoc and the Apocrypha,
the apocryphal texts.
It would have forbidden books of the Bible where for example,
you have the apocalypse of Abraham in which Abrahams ascension into code and
code heaviness described.
But if you look at it from a modern day perspective,
what we can read their reads as if he is entering some type of a spaceship.
He's taken up there and then he is boarding some type of an orbiting space
station.
And guys,
I know that this sounds apps so lutely bat shit crazy,
but the questions remain.
How did our ancestors describe something like this?
That if you look at it from a modern day perspective,
it reminds of a trip to space,
right?
And why is it that all these gods exist in the sky?
How come these gods,
I mean this is Gabriel or,
or rather,
um,
who,
who is Satan was Satan Lucifer.
Lucifer was as original Denise Lucifer.
That was what he was [inaudible] and that means bringer of light.
And only then he was turning to Satan or into something evil because he was
outcast.
And I in the ancient alien theory proposes that,
uh,
what we have here is a huge misconception that this has had never anything to do
with the devil
or within,
well,
you know,
fighting God or God fighting the devil,
but that there might have been a mutiny on some type of a spaceship and,
uh,
you know,
they were cast off not because they were,
uh,
you know,
Satan's,
but because they were,
you know,
we get along mute mutineers you know,
because there were no angels back then.
There were no,
there was no,
there was no thing between God and to devil.
It's all a total misconception of a total misunderstood visit.
So they were like,
not extra terrestrials like the devil's were like Nazis,
like the enemy.
Like if you were going to have like someone who is your,
your enemy,
if somebody broke off and you want to describe it,
those are the evil people.
I mean,
you could create,
they were still,
they were still at the same,
the idea that was proposed,
was it theirs?
They were still part of the same crew.
And then,
you know,
just like,
uh,
during a pirate days and stuff like that,
they would be mutinies going on back then.
Well maybe that's why you can start off on an island.
You burn forever cause they nuked the shit out of you.
Maybe that's what it is.
Well yeah,
exactly.
You have to ask yourself the question,
where did the ideas for heaven and hell even come from the whole fire and
brimstone thing?
And if you look at the orange origins of that,
you know,
it all came because of flank furnaces,
flank furnaces.
Are you kidding me?
What was that?
Couldn't be.
There's,
we're not idiots.
Supervolcanoes yeah.
Well what about that?
I mean if you looked at that,
if you looked inside a volcano,
you'd think that's hell,
that's the center.
But a supervolcano doesn't take off or fly away.
That's true.
You know,
so that's why,
you know,
the flank furnaces think to me is very fascinating because they were,
they were familiar with furnaces,
but they knew as much as anybody,
furnaces don't fly.
And all of a sudden we have flying furnaces that are,
were bigger and made noise.
And you know,
the earth trembled and dust and smoke and craziness.
So you know,
they didn't have the vocabulary.
What are these descriptions?
Yeah,
what are these descriptions of explaining?
It is a,
is a very tricky thing and it's real easy for people to just go pop,
what is this fucking Ufo nonsense?
What the fuck are these people talking about?
But if you really just stopped and thought about it for a sec,
if something did happen ten thousand twelve thousand thirty thousand years ago
or whatever the fuck it was,
how much do you think would be around?
How much evidence would that is?
That is a wonderful question because a lot of times they're like,
you know,
how come we've never found a remnant of a machine?
Or how come we've never found a crashed spaceship?
Because first of all,
if it's a technological device and it's left out in the open on your phone,
I can find my phone.
If I lose it,
you can't find your spaceship.
Yeah.
You know,
but you need out there for 12,000 years,
it will disintegrate into dust number one.
So it depends on where it was stored.
But at the same time,
you know,
when was the last time you saw a construction site and after they finished
building everything,
you walk in there and all the construction materials and the construction tools
are still there.
People that build stuff,
they bring their tools and then when they leave they take their tools with them.
And I think that that was the same,
those extra terrestrials from thousands of years ago that those tools were
extremely valuable.
So they had an inventory and they said,
you know,
machine x,
y,
Z is missing.
Go find it.
So they hook people up,
they let them use a machine.
Yes,
they build this shit and they all right,
we're out of here.
Right.
That would explain a lot of things.
One of the things that would explain is in this,
again,
this is real,
there are certain pieces of construction that we really have no idea how to like
they did like the h block that you have right there.
And how many of these blocks are in Puma?
Pimco,
the h blocks,
uh,
I think either 13 or 17 have been found and archeologists are at the moment
trying to reassemble Puma Punko to its former glory because right now,
and by the way,
if somebody really or in three d graph,
so literally ambien.
And the unfortunate thing is,
and I've seen pictures,
I haven't been there lately,
but I've seen pictures through who were sent to me by friends and the blocks are
being put together completely in the wrong places.
Why are they moving blocks?
Well,
some blocks have disappeared Joe.
Someone stole blocks.
No,
actually I think that they used to a,
um,
what do you call these hammers that you use out in the street?
Jack Hammer.
Jackhammer.
So use jackhammers.
And they basically just disintegrated some of these blocks because they didn't
fit into the scheme what they're trying to do.
And it seems as if some of these professors or scientists have never played
lego's a treacherous tetris in their entire lives.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute.
What a dumb idea to modes.
Horse.
A sensor.
Chabot,
but,
well,
it's so stupid because it's going to confuse our ancestors.
Well,
excuse me,
our predecessor thing,
our heirs,
our heirs.
Yeah.
Well the thing is that,
you know,
predecessor tunecore's to steal the foma Puente cu.
Dot.
Mine is a place that is in ruins.
It's not,
it's not like a clear,
exactly.
So then of course you also have to have to ask yourself the question,
how the hell was it destroyed?
How did he get into this stage?
Unless they must've been some deliberate destruction.
Well,
for a giant,
giant cataclysmic event,
who knows?
It could have been easily.
And maybe that also explains why at 12,000 feet,
maybe the environment was different because one of the things that they're
saying about the pre dinosaur era and one of the reasons why they think that
animals may have been so large back then and so much different than they are
today,
is that the actual atmosphere may have been different then than it is today.
And the impact in,
uh,
the,
the Yucatan that they believe happened 65 billion years ago,
that killed off everything.
And then from there,
flowering plants emerged.
And you know,
the emergence of mammals is as the higher intellect.
And dominant part of the food chain.
But before all that they'd thinking that the,
the environment might have been different.
And if that is the case,
maybe a at 12,000 feet,
you know,
a long fucking time ago there was more oxygen up there.
Maybe it was a different wash here.
Here's the thing that,
you know,
some people have that that entire Indian plateau of the Bolivian highlands was
at one point way lower than it currently is.
And if that is the case then you have to ask yourself the question,
when was that in number two?
All around this entire plateau up there,
you find fossils of a saltwater fish.
So at some point that whole thing had to have been covered with ocean water and
where are,
you know,
at least a thousand miles inland from the Pacific Ocean.
So it is such a mind fuck,
it's not even funny.
So how many years,
like I know there was,
is it Tia Naco where they said it was close to what they believe or what are the
alternative theories is it was close to 28,000 years.
20,000 years ago.
It was on the water.
Yes.
Oh No,
no,
no near the water.
But Puma Pimco might've been a port on the water at some point,
a harbor of some point in time,
but that would mean that,
that they had there've been ocean water at 12,000,
500 feet above sea level unless,
you know,
there was a cataclysmic event that raised the entire plateau in a relatively
short period of time.
Now,
why war that would it do it uniformly so that everything was like level when it
got up to him.
I am not a geologist,
I have no idea.
But what's also fascinating is that right next to a Puma,
Puma [inaudible] is Lake Titicaca,
which is the highest navigable lake in the world.
And um,
you know,
people have also suggested that,
uh,
to Lake Titicaca was so big that it actually connected with Puma Punahou and
that Puma punker was merely a harbor by a lake and not by the ocean.
That's what I was thinking of.
That was the,
uh,
the store that I had read.
It wasn't,
it was a,
it wasn't Tinoco.
Nahko was uh,
the other one will say it again.
Puma.
Which Gacaca?
Yeah,
that's what I remembered that I was trying to recall.
So how far away is that?
Like in miles,
but 50,
50.
That's shit that ain't show.
No.
If you think about how many different times there's,
uh,
been,
lakes that we found that a dry lake beds like groom lake where area 51 is used
to be a lake.
Right.
You know,
and there there was,
there's a lot of dry lake beds,
grand the world and used to be a body of water.
What is it at the bottom and some spots still?
Well,
yeah,
the rivers,
you've got the Colorado River going,
but it used to be even bigger,
something cut through all that shit,
which is incredible if you look at the Grand Canyon and think that that was all
carved by all river.
Like what a saying,
man,
river and fucking carved this shit to the ground.
How long did that take?
Exactly.
It's really tough for us to wrap our heads around the idea of 28,000 years ago
now.
And then,
and then we miles a lake ain't shit for 20 and then we claim that we know
everything.
She to me the moment someone claims to have all the answers run for the hills
man.
Well it's,
nobody knows.
The real issue is a lot of times we have a few things that we know for a fact
and then we start teaching those few things.
And then as in,
especially in terms of ancient history,
there's a lot of speculation.
There's a lot of,
well what we think is this and once they start teaching that,
that's when things get tricky.
Because if you have a theory and you teach that theory and then all sudden some
other shit comes up that might make all that Shit you've been teaching for 10
years.
Utter Horse Shit,
that's hard to accept for a lot of people.
Well cause it's their ego is attached to what they believe in their,
you know,
attached to what they're teaching.
Oh f absolutely.
All of that is a problem in academia isn't it?
And when it comes to,
you know,
all these ancient sites,
of course,
and Ellen with likened it to the same thing where,
you know,
it doesn't matter.
Here we are in Pasadena and there's the Huntington Library right here.
And the Huntington Library has some of the most precious books in the world.
Some of them are textbooks,
beautifully leather bound textbooks that were used at universities at the best
universities in the world,
you know,
in London or here in the states,
or uh,
well not back then the states,
but uh,
you know,
at different places of education and those books today,
you,
you look at them and I challenge you to find anything in there that's a science
book that still holds true today.
Right?
Yet,
those books were printed so that the students at the universities could read and
study and perform tests on these things.
And that was the cutting edge of science back in the day.
And today,
nothing holds true.
So I think it's going to be the same thing about the way less stuff that we know
about.
We'll be wrong,
but there will be things that a hundred years from now that we think today is
true.
A hundred years from now,
we will know that in fact we were wrong.
Do you think that if the shit hits the fan and the aliens come,
the government,
we'll call you,
say Giorgio you want to come down here and take care of this?
We need someone who understands what the fuck is going on.
Look,
I'll go.
But no,
I don't think it's going to happen.
No Way.
Because you volunteering yourself as the representative of human beings to the
extra show world that has already actually been taken care of by someone at the
UN,
believe it or not.
Yes,
yes,
absolutely.
They um,
yeah,
the,
he's the,
he's the liaison between aliens and human being.
That's his gig.
Should the case comes,
you have another job too.
I hope he has no,
no idea.
I hope this isn't something we're actually finish things.
It's so funny that you know,
they have not chosen somebody who,
you know,
has chosen this as a,
the stuff that they do.
Um,
you know,
cause I think that might be important,
but,
you know,
call me crazy.
Well,
uh,
maybe the guy to us as the UN fascinating.
A closet alien dude.
Oh,
who knows?
You mad that you could get that Gig.
It's like,
what?
Like a girl.
Oh my God.
I didn't even get to audition for that role.
And now he's even Chelsea.
And I just think it's funny,
just like,
you know,
one of the first,
uh,
alien movies or,
or,
or science fiction movies that,
that
in my opinion,
uh,
proposed the real idea in promethium if you go out there,
you have to bring at least one archaeologist prometheus's the first movie,
who has done that in every other a science fiction movie that you have.
There's never an archeologist on board,
you know,
and to me it's like,
are you kidding me?
That's the first person that you go somewhere because of comparison of our past
with what's whatever's going on at the destination planet.
But instead they bring a whole bunch of Yahoos with them that,
you know,
of course it's all entertainment.
I understand.
But I think that the whole Prometheans thing,
it's a,
it's a beautiful movie.
It's a great entertainment.
I didn't like it.
It's really good.
Look at,
but I didn't like it.
I thought there's just too many hokey fucking moments in it.
It's,
I thought it could have been an incredible movie,
but it seemed like there's seemed like some,
I dunno,
I would love to sit down with Ridley Scott and get high with him and go,
what happened man?
Get him on the podcast.
Scott's not doing my fucking podcast.
I'm doing a surprise guys.
Podcasts.
Most especially not after I told them that I don't like for me.
Yes.
He'd be like,
Hey,
fucking punk ass bitch.
Did fear factor shitting on Prometheans but a,
I loved alien.
I love gladiator.
I think he's amazing.
He does amazing movies.
But that movie,
it just was,
it was okay.
I would even see it again if it was on TV or something.
I might even buy the DVD just to watch it for a little while,
but it just,
it could have been so much more.
But it was a,
the idea behind it that,
you know,
we were engineered and created.
It's a,
they handled that I thought pretty well.
I thought they handled.
Uh,
it was,
it was fascinating.
You know the concept behind it though,
the black stuff that becomes the alien,
there's a little kind of a pain the ass and it was hard to wrap your head
around.
Like they have a chart of the,
the morphology and like how,
how people become that thing,
how that thing is created,
how the actual alien from the first movie aliens,
he have actually charted it out.
Like where it comes from like this.
Like when a man gets in,
check that out and gives it to a woman,
then it creates this kind of a fucking octopus looking thing.
And when the woman got pregnant that's why it's because it was a man who got
infected.
Then he impregnated her and then the infection takes that form so that it
produces one type of offspring or if one of the engineer's gets infected then it
produces another type of thing.
And it's like they've all plotted it all out.
Like at the end when the end,
spoiler,
spoiler alert,
shouldn't be saying any spoilers.
I shouldn't tell people what happened.
It's not bad way,
but it's just not as good as alien alien one.
It's the shit still to this day,
one of the greatest movies of all time aliens was good to aliens is good and
differently different but good.
Very Fun.
But the aliens were too easy to kill.
That's what pissed me off.
It's like all of a sudden you can kill him like that because the first one,
that one alien was super sneaky and fucked everybody up.
Now they're like real obvious in your face running at you.
Like,
come on man.
Like they were like masters.
Like the first alien was always creeping up on bitches and then jacking him and
the second one like and is running at you and then you have to shot it.
Um,
it was still a fun movie,
but in my opinion,
they change the characteristics of the thing.
If aliens was,
all these things were super clever and all these things are really stealthy and
they moved on,
that would've been an even more terrifying movie.
It was.
It was really hard to kill them.
But they're just out there running at you and you shoot them.
I mean,
it seems change the whole fucking movie,
you know,
Sam,
the advent of video games,
is that what it is?
That's what it is.
Became like a,
uh,
aliens vs Predator.
How'd that happen?
Terrible.
Terrible,
ridiculous.
Combining two fucking silly movies.
One of them takes place in the future.
Fuck.
Why don't it takes place now?
One of it takes place,
like how fucking thousand years from now and these they're all bat.
Come on right out of here.
No,
I love it.
It doesn't have to have some sort of an alien vs Predator didn't have some sort
of an ancient aliens yes to it did it,
did
that,
uh,
the predators were worshiped by the Maya and there,
there was this fight going on between the predators and to Maya or the aliens
ever since Mayan Times.
And the mines were in between.
And that's how they disappear because they all got eaten up and things like
that.
So I mean,
interesting,
but a trip.
Yeah.
What,
what is the
best version a and you think in like science fiction of what alien life is going
to be.
Do you think it was for me atheists
most recently?
Yes.
But then you have to ask yourself,
you know,
who created the engineers,
who engineered engineers and this is why,
you know,
in my opinion,
you can never really lose your belief in some all encompassing force in the
universe,
which I referred to as God.
Uh,
you know,
or it was actually the vice vice versa.
Um,
you know,
but other science fiction movies that portray did wonderfully was,
the first total recall or star gate,
the,
the original theatrical release,
um,
mission to Mars.
All those movies were wonderful,
ancient alien type movies that describe the ancient alien theory very nicely,
not necessarily to the,
you know,
in Star Gates case,
uh,
accurately in my opinion,
because I don't think we were ever a slave species,
for example,
as so many other ancient alien theorists a subscribe to that decision on as
well.
Right?
Yeah.
And that'll always,
and he knows his,
I told him this when he was still alive that I actually disagreed with him.
Daniel,
let's agree with [inaudible] of course.
But the thing is it doesn't matter very cocky.
It doesn't matter because in the end,
the theory itself that we were visited remains the same whether we are a slave
species or not.
And I chose to think that we're not.
Why do you choose irrelevant that why do you make that distinction?
Because he proposed that we were created as worker bees to mine gold mine gold
for the Anunnaki who needed gold for their atmosphere on their home planet named
Nibiru meets you cock who has proposed or calculated that,
uh,
there is the same amount of gold on any,
um,
body found in the universe.
So to suggest that they had to come specifically here to find gold,
logically speaking doesn't make much sense
saying that gold exists on Saturn.
Gold exists on Neptune.
Every single planetary body in all have the same amount of gold.
Yes.
Because it all expanded from the Big Bang.
It all was distributed evenly.
What about gas plants?
Gas?
You know,
you would have to ask Kako for this,
but the whole idea that solid objects contain the same amount of gold,
what he proposed that,
you know,
aliens wouldn't have to come here if they wanted to mine gold.
Well,
maybe it's both.
Maybe they came here to engineer people,
but they also need gold.
So they engineered people to make gold.
But it's both.
It's not just,
it's like a,
a,
a dual project,
Sean.
Just an evolutionary.
Yeah,
no,
that's,
that's an interesting,
uh,
um,
you know,
approach to looking at it.
However,
you know,
the whole slave species thing,
it feeds into this current belief that we are beholden to someone else.
That we are not in control of our lives,
that we and our governments are ruled by aliens and that there's Reptilians and
all that bullshit that,
uh,
you know,
people really think that they are no longer in charge of their own lives.
That everything is,
you know,
a,
a planned and the overlooked by our alien overlord.
And that to me,
you know,
even to a guy like me that is too fucking far out and come on,
just go back,
come back to reality.
Put your feet on the ground and trying to differentiate between what's actually
feasible and something that's just,
you know,
the sciences are you
and I part ways cause I think it is feasible.
I think if you look at us and what we do to dolphins,
we forced them to do tricks for fish.
What we do to kill a whale.
So you know,
which we know are intelligent creatures,
right?
Just can't understand what they're saying.
They're intelligent enough to understand voice commands so they understand when
we want specific things and they do them by voice command.
And yet we don't understand what the fuck they're saying.
We don't know.
Walked down.
Many people or scientists have been trying now ever since we were able to record
stuff.
Right.
But the,
but the point is we know they're intelligent life forms and we slave him,
we enslave them.
We absolutely in slave dolphins,
we absolutely in slave killer whales,
we know they're intelligent and we just assume that because they can't create
culture cause they can't alter their environment because they don't have thumbs.
We know they have language complex language.
So we know that unlike any other animal on the earth,
besides humans,
that they are actually communicating with very specific words.
In fact,
they have dialects and a very complex language that we can't decipher.
We know like monkeys have like certain things that this means the cat.
You know,
this is like the,
you know,
they communicate with each other.
Just very rudimentary and crude.
Not like dolphins.
Dolphins have a complicated language as do whales,
but yet look what we do to them,
right?
Put Him in a fucking cage.
I think.
I think the captivity of animals except for preservation is barbaric.
It is,
but it's done and it's done by every single animal on this planet that has a
power over another pow,
uh,
animal.
It exploited and it seems to be a pattern in the universe.
It seems to be.
If you look at biological life,
completely objective on this planet,
everything that's more intelligent or more powerful fucks up everything that's
not,
and that's just the way it is.
Monkeys are very intelligent little things and chimps eat them,
they grab them and they ripped them apart and they eat them while they're alive.
And we know that.
And we know that we do crazy shit to monkeys.
We do experiments on them,
we take chimps and we put them in laboratories and we put lipstick on him and
shit.
See if they die.
I mean,
that's what we do.
That's what we do.
And I think that if you look at that pattern,
our pattern of enslaving dolphins and killer whales,
because we have the ability to alter environment that they don't have,
you know,
because of that,
I would say why wouldn't something much more intelligent than a human being
that's been around for a million years.
That's completely unimpressed with some fucking caveman or some,
you know,
Australia [inaudible] some stupid fuck out there running around picking
mushrooms off a cow.
Shit,
why wouldn't we enslave them if we is some super alien forced,
it's a billion years more advanced than us.
Why we're saying if we do it to everything that's on this planet,
why would you,
we have this weird thing of assuming that things are altruistic,
that the universe is going to be more advanced morally than we are,
but we show zero sign personal evolution.
Personally,
I think that as society who is able to travel between the stars has at least
reached such a level of awareness
that they have at least stopped killing each other on their own home planet.
Because I agree with you that there is good and evil out there.
I agree with you that there might be civilizations out there from different
plans of warring with each other,
but I think that until you can reach that level that you have to come to the
understanding that we have to clean up our house first.
So that because,
because I think that you see the whole warring thing and you know,
fighting,
creating wars over religion and oil and all those different things in the end,
but we have to understand is that we are on this planet together and once we
realize that,
I think that is when we will make contact and that is when we can band together
and potentially fight and threat if there is one.
But like I said,
there's good and evil out there.
So the fact that we've been around until 2012 after having gone through two
genetic bottleneck situations on planet earth with the human race,
I think we're in pretty good shape of not being annihilated by whoever
some are proposing will annihilate us on the 21st of December,
2012 which is total nonsense.
I think if you look at our state of existence on this earth,
if you look at Kim Kardashian,
if you look at Obama and uh,
you know,
Mubarak in Egypt and you look at the chaos in the world and you look at us
pulling the oil out of the ground and if you look at us just polluting the ocean
at pulling the resources out,
we act like a prison colony that doesn't have a fucking warden.
We're just super duper duper complicated.
We,
our whole culture acts like someone who got to this place,
um,
accidentally or was,
was helped by whether it's humans that are super advanced or aliens or,
or some sort of a thing.
It looks like what a prison.
You've got to go soon we go.
It looks like what you would expect if a prison was overrun,
I mean were,
were so irresponsible and how we pollute the earth so irresponsible in how we
utilize this incredible technology.
No,
but then there are religions.
We've slaves,
nutty.
But then there are religions that propose,
oh,
it's all right because when Jesus comes back,
he will,
he will pick us up in a spaceship and we will be brought to new earth now ha.
And in that is the plant that we should keep.
It should take care of.
Now what an irresponsible teaching or proposition is that,
oh yeah,
let this mother earth go to fucking shit.
But who cares?
Because we will be picked up and brought to another planet.
Are you fucking shitting me?
That is no longer religion,
but that is the height of human arrogance and insanity.
That is a crazy argument as well.
And we were crazy a idea as well,
but I don't think it's outside the realm of possibility that we were in fact
created two n and engineered to work for these super intelligent beings.
I,
yeah,
I agree with you that it's very possible.
Well,
I mean of course it's possible.
Listen,
I really do not have the answers.
But if you think about what I'm saying is if you think about how we exploit
everything else below us,
we're assuming that somewhere up the ladder that stops.
But in the life that we see my proposition,
yes,
but you look at the life that we see,
the intelligent life that we see despite pita and despite,
you know,
people that are trying to propagate piece.
It's not existing,
but that's just more more today than ever before.
But there is at the same time a paradigm shift happening that we're experiencing
because I agree,
but there's no lines where people are trying to break free the Dawes because
it's,
it's fluctuating that the time of the dolphins I think will come,
especially since every day more and more people are embracing vegetarianism and
even veganism that's frozen closes.
It's delicious and cows are stupid.
And that's,
that's,
that's his.
But it's a dumb thing is a paradigm shift that has never happened before and
it's happening fast.
Right.
But isn't the argument that that's because
of surplus and because people have the first world option of being a vegetarian,
which is,
you know,
in,
in most cultures it's about staying alive and you need protein.
And if the only food availables fish,
you're eating fish.
If cows are available,
you're eating cows.
And as our civilization,
you know,
becomes more and more complex than we have these uh,
possibilities.
But I see what you're saying.
You know,
I see that I would love it if that was true.
If everything eventually got to a point where you,
these,
these super intelligent being so far advanced from us would look at us and go,
ah,
you guys are,
you guys are pretty cool.
We're not going to fuck with you.
And when we come here,
we're not going to make,
you were going to let you play with house and we're not going to,
we're not going to exploit you the way you do.
And every other form of life does on this planet.
I think that was one thing that Promethean has got that I thought was pretty
probably dead on the disdain that the engineers would have for humans after what
happened and how are we do,
how we turned out the same way we would if we went to the fucking jungle.
And there was a tribe of chimps that had created electricity and they were
shooting lightning bolts at each other.
And you'd be like,
bitch,
what the fuck are you doing?
We would completely take it away from them and if we were going to change them
and fix them,
we would have no problem.
Hence,
that's why we have stories of these UFOS disabling nuclear plants.
Hence that's why we haven't tried it and the apes.
But we take a champion and make it super intelligent and it gets fucking really
pissed at us.
But we do it.
Giorgio sucralose has to leave,
ladies and gentlemen,
but this has been a fucking awesome talk as always,
sir,
we've got to do this more.
I've been such a privilege to be here.
So fun.
Like we said earlier,
if you guys want to come out and see me,
yes,
tonight the universal shirts and tonight 7:00 PM and you can get
tickets@twokilosontourdoteventbrite.com bless.
Sell that.
Spell that because that ain't easy.
Names.
That's t as in Tom,
s as in Sam,
O u,
k a l o s on tour dot event,
e v e n t and then bright spelled B,
r I t e.
Dot com.
Well where's your,
what is your website so they can go and legendary times.com is all that
information available and legendary dot.
Yes in the front page,
the front page and I can be found on Twitter at two kilos and on Facebook,
facebook.com forward slash George sucralose fans.
And if you can't spell it,
if you can't remember,
my name is Joe Rogan and it's really easy if you go to my Twitter and today is a
the 26th of June,
he will see Giorgio's Twitter handle cause otherwise I don't want,
I don't want you to lose any potential people that might be coming out to the
seminar and coming to hang with you and uh,
and following you on Twitter.
You're the fucking man dude.
I love it Georgia and I've been throwing us for a while now,
man.
We met in Vegas and hanged out and hung out and hung out.
So,
uh,
I got to know the real Georgio,
the man behind the ancient aliens and I'm fucking flattered that you came by
again man.
We had a great time.
Are you kidding me?
Is My privilege to brother Joe?
Thank you so much.
I do this more often.
Thanks.
All right,
my dirty friends.
Uh,
we got a lot of shit coming up this week.
Tomorrow we've got little Jimmy Norton that'll be a later show.
He's doing the tonight show and he's coming right over here.
So that'll probably be like a six o'clock.
And then on Friday we got my pal Adam Score,
Ge who is the,
uh,
the,
the guy who produced the union,
the documentary on medical marijuana in British Columbia,
or excuse me,
marijuana in British Columbia.
Uh,
which is a fantastic documentary on just the whole history of the illegality of
marijuana.
I mean,
one of the best pro cannabis documentaries it's ever been done.
And by way done by a guy who doesn't smoke weed,
uh,
maybe does now.
Um,
Adam's to shit though,
and he's going to be here on Friday and we also have next week we're trying to
work out Josh Barnett and Kevin Pereira.
So both,
uh,
are on tap.
We'll figure out when that's happening next week and perhaps one of our comedian
friends as well.
Maybe Justin Martindale.
Yeah,
he,
uh,
tweeted me today and uh,
we'll will eventually work that out to Yo.
But,
uh,
thank you everybody for tuning in as always.
We do this because you guys,
and uh,
I can speak for Brian because I know that he,
uh,
is,
just as thrilled and honored and appreciates all you guys as much as I do.
Cause this is a,
we're having a crazy time.
We never thought this podcast would ever become anything close to what it is
now.
And uh,
it's,
you know,
the feedback that you guys give us,
his fucking tremendous and we'll never stop doing this,
right Brian.
We ain't going nowhere bitches.
Don't forget we have a show here Friday.
Oh,
that's right.
We got another powerful super show here at the Ice House and we're going to have
to start calling them super show shows cause he's deaf.
Squad shows are just ridiculous.
We had,
you know,
I mean,
we have shows where on any given night you have dom Irrera,
Greg Fitzsimmons,
Doug Benson,
Doug fucking name.
I'm Brendan Walsh.
I mean Joe,
Joey Diaz,
Sam triply,
Ari should fear so many of our top comedian friends come by.
And we usually have like 10 comics that go up and it's only 15 bucks and it's at
the Ice House in Pasadena,
which is easily one of the greatest comedy clubs on earth.
One of the oldest in the world,
the comedy club.
Uh,
it's been existence in existence here since the 1950s.
Yeah,
this is a crazy place.
First it was like a jazz club or something like that and then it became a comedy
club.
But it's also like a museum.
Like there's all these pictures of guys in the wall from like the 1970s.
It's a mind blowing place and it's an awesome comedy club and the people that
run it,
Bob is the coolest guy on the planet and he's such a nice guy.
The guy owns it and they're so cool to everybody.
All the,
all the comedians here.
It's a,
it's an honor to be here and to do our show out of here.
So,
uh,
that's it.
So this Friday,
who's joining us so far?
Uh,
I mean it started yet.
You haven't even started.
We're going to get all interns who were in town,
but it'll definitely be me and I'll definitely be Brian.
Jimmy,
maybe Jimmy wants to,
I felt,
I think he has to go back to New York.
I think he's only here until Thursday,
but maybe if he's here,
fuck yeah,
I'm going to cough it.
Tim is to at cvs around and we'll get a,
either way it'll be a stack show and that's this Friday night.
So what's a anything else?
Yeah.
Can you just say something real quick?
Uh,
we're,
we're having a death squad show at comic con this year.
2012 it's a,
and tickets are on sale right now.
It's July 13th.
It's a Friday.
Uh,
it's going to be me,
Ari Shaffir,
uh,
Sam Tripoli.
I might have that day off.
Yeah.
And you should stop by Matt.
What is it?
July one.
July 13th at the San Diego at comic con 2012.
How many tickets did we go?
Sold?
I haven't even checked,
but uh,
if you could live 13th.
Yeah,
if you go to American comedy code at that night off.
Is that when,
um,
that's when comicon is down in San Diego.
Yeah.
I thought we just wanted to go to that dude.
You should,
if you want to go,
I can get you in.
I mean,
I'm sure you can get an easily put it,
but yeah,
it's,
it's a party,
man.
It's,
uh,
it's a,
it's the whole weekend and then the following night,
you know,
when she show Patrick,
oh wow.
You know what we should do?
Is it Naddie show down there?
Up here?
It's the exact same place.
The American Comedy Co,
uh,
it's in San Diego.
You got to do a live,
not a show or we're doing two,
nine,
two,
two 90 show Saturday and to test squad shows Friday,
you should have little booths set off so people could just beat off while
they're looking at her.
That's all right.
Just to have like a little confessional booths where you just have a little hole
in the wall that you could peak out at her and just beat off right in front of
her.
No,
don't do that.
That's a terrible idea.
But maybe I'll,
maybe I'll join you guys.
Maybe we'll schedule a live podcast on there or something,
Huh?
Yeah,
sure.
Let's do something crazy.
Let's do a podcast,
like whatever.
We'll fucking planted it out.
Don't you worry.
You bitches.
Okay.
All right.
That's it.
Thank you to everybody for tuning into the show.
Thank you,
Georgia.
Sucralose.
Thank you to the fleshlight.
Go to Joe rogan.net and you know what to do.
You use the code name Rogan,
and you'll save 15% off.
Thank you.
Two on at.com as well.
That's o,
n n I t,
makers of Alpha Brain shroom,
tech sport,
shroom,
tech,
immune,
new mood,
and now kettle bells and battle ropes.
Go check all that shit out.
You use a code name,
Rogan.
Save yourself some cash on some brain food son.
Uh,
that's it for today and we'll see you guys soon.
Oh,
thanks for sucker punch soccer punch entertainment for setting up,
said,
hooking me up with a Alienware too.
Very cool.
Follow Alienware on Twitter if you feel like it in soccer punch and red band
fall red band,
red ban and fucking shows over,
goddammit.
So,
yeah,
yeah.